And we're live Mr Sharma.
Welcome.
Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being here,
man.
Appreciate it.
I have been paying attention to your
work for a long time.
It's a no,
you're the one who bakes.
Yes.
I'm one of those guys.
I'm sure you've got a lot but a bunch of
your books here.
Thanks for bringing those in.
I really appreciate that.
You have some stuff to read.
Now,
how did you get involved in skepticism?
I know you started off as a cyclist,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
Well I was a,
a bike racer from 1980 to about 1990,
about 10 years in between when I was
first in college.
I went to pepperdine and then cal state
fullerton.
And then uh,
I just was burned out.
I had a master's degree and uh,
I just decided I didn't want to do
another six straight years of phd work.
So I quit and I went over the,
a placement office at cal state
fullerton and said,
well,
I need a job.
They said,
well,
can you do?
I said nothing.
And I'm,
I have no skills.
I'm a college student but I like to
write,
so I got a job at a bike magazine,
my first job out of college and it was a
trade magazine for um,
for uh,
the bike industry,
uh,
but I got right into cycling right away
about a bike the first week and when you
weren't a bike rider before this job.
And I went to um,
a big event at the Griffith Park where
they had a yoplait yogurt 50 kilometer
bike race.
And Jonathan Boyer was the Big Star.
He had the first American to do the Tour
de France.
And I saw him.
It's like,
wow,
this is a cool sport.
So I just got into it.
I just started riding and racing and
then I did.
We started race across America in 1992
in 1982.
And so I quit my job and just did that
for,
for a decade.
I had corporate sponsors and we had ABC
wide world of sports that contract with
them to film it.
And we turned it into a little little
mini culture business.
And you know,
ultra and ultra endurance sports were
just taking off the iron man.
It became famous in the early eighties,
John Howard,
who won,
it was one of the first to do the race
across America with me and two other
guys and I did a rod dog sled race.
And then soon after that,
we're all those,
um,
a sort of long distance mixed sport type
things where you run and hike and swim.
And,
and,
uh,
anyway,
so that was just part of that culture
and you know,
I was young and single and didn't have a
house or mortgage,
you know,
that stuff.
So you can do,
do those kinds of things.
That's a fascinating thing to get into
too,
because I mean that,
that's a real rabbit hole.
You get into two when you started into
cycling and endurance racing and you,
you,
you understand the culture and you get
into those people there.
There are bizarre group of people.
They are,
yes,
actually,
uh,
the subculture of ultra endurance
athletes as a number of Weirdos.
But so does the sort of skeptical
movement.
I've decided that all kind of social
subcultures have a handful of real
weirdos.
The people that show up at your door
like,
can I stay here this weekend?
What?
No,
you have skeptics that.
Because there are also skeptical there.
There.
There's some oddballs there for sure.
That's always going to be the case.
I think you're absolutely right.
That and about groups
you're always going have like outliers
or strange strange,
but it's all right,
but the endurance racing in and of
itself,
like the idea of pushing your body to
the limits is a really fascinating sport
because pretty much everyone can ride a
bike.
It's not like you're doing something
like ballet where you.
I couldn't imagine doing,
you know,
I've watched like some people do like
flips and gymnastics and stuff and I,
although I know the human body can do
that.
I'm like,
yeah,
I can't see myself doing it,
but I can get on a bike.
That's all right.
The key is find something you like to do
and that you're good at.
You know,
my wife's a beautiful dancer.
I,
you know,
I've tried to dancing lessons with it.
I just can't do it and I just got two
left feet.
Can't do it.
What I meant is though that it's one of
those things where a normal person can
do it,
so to,
but to do it the way a Lance Armstrong
can do it or the way of Greg Lamon can
do it.
You get into that weird area where you
just tweaking every single aspect of
your body,
the way you eat,
the way you sleep,
what you do,
your mental attitude,
your,
your motivation.
And did you get down that rabbit hole
one?
Absolutely.
It's all I did,
you know,
just,
it was a 40 hour week but really more
like a 60 hour a week job where you're
training,
but you know,
uh,
it,
there's a lot of preparation before you
go out on a ride,
when you come back from a ride and then
you add weights or stretching,
yoga,
whatever it ends up being,
you know,
an all day process.
How long did it take before you got into
all those people that are into epo and
blood dope in?
When I was raised in the eighties,
there was no epo,
a blood doping was legal and it was done
by people I knew and the 84 Olympics,
uh,
on the 84 Olympic team,
I know some of the people that did it,
they used their own blood or a
relative's blood.
They just stored it and packed it in.
It wasn't even band until after the 84
Olympics when it was found out.
The American team did it.
And then the,
uh,
the,
whoever,
not that UCI,
the Olympic Committee said,
okay,
no,
no blood doping,
but it works.
I didn't try it.
A race across America is kind of a
different sort of competition.
It's more of you against yourself and
the in the clock,
you know,
you hardly ever see the other people out
there on the road.
So,
um,
and I wasn't into the idea of taking
your blood out and packing it back in
and sort of creeped me out.
And there were no drugs that you could
take.
I mean,
things like steroids,
it's not going to do it for a cyclist.
It the miracle Vpo is that it packs in
more red blood cells much faster than
say trading at high altitude and uh,
and you don't have to do the creepy
thing with story and bags of blood and,
and then the blood cells die or the
blood gets infected.
Uh,
I mean I got Hep c when I was in college
and I had a back surgery.
I had a tumor on my spine and I had to
have it taken out and I had been taking
a lot of aspirin for pain.
It was in pain for years and so they had
to do this,
a blood transfusion in night.
This was 1976 and there was no test for
this.
So I got Hep C.
and so after that I thought,
oh,
blood blood doping packing.
That just sort of creeped me out.
And there were people that were getting
sick from blood doping know you take the
blood,
you put in a,
you store it,
maybe it's stored properly,
maybe it's not.
And then you get blood infections and
that's not,
that's,
that's dangerous is Hep c the disease.
That was recently in the news because
there was a young guy who owns some
pharmaceutical company and they charged
a ridiculous amount of money for it.
Yes,
correct.
Because you can get the.
I've been cured.
Know I'm a kaiser patient and I did it
10 years ago and wiped it out within a
month and I did the six month treatment
and I've had been clear ever since.
But the drugs aren't that expensive if
you do it through an Hmo,
they just.
It's just built into it should be part
of your any healthcare system and so
yeah,
somebody was doctoring the search,
cheating the system or something like
that.
Yeah,
there was Jimmy,
you know the story behind it,
right?
That it was a young Martin.
Sure.
Kelly is that.
I think it was Hep c or HIV,
I think maybe some different,
different medications.
He's got a company that works for a lot
of pharmaceutical,
so it couldn't be both and the
accusation once he was price gouging and
charging ridiculous.
It took you six months to get over a
well,
my first blood test after a month of
taking the,
the antiviral and the interferon was the
combination would they use 10 years ago
and within the first blood test it was
gone.
Undetectable.
They said,
yeah,
but you got to do the whole six month
treatment.
That's our program.
All right.
So I did it.
Uh,
I was one of the fortunate ones that
didn't get sick from the drugs.
Some people just are laid out,
they can't,
they can't do exercise or function,
but I didn't have any problems.
So you tested negative but they still
made you continue the medication?
Yeah.
Is it because just because you're in a
sort of a trials and it's like this is
what we do.
You've got to do the six months.
So.
All right.
Oh,
okay.
But he didn't mess with,
you know,
that was all right.
Yep.
So,
you know,
back then,
um,
that was the only thing you could do
with was blood doping when epo was
introduced in the early nineties,
that really made a big difference.
And as you know,
Greg,
I first discovered this when his
teammates came to him a and said,
you know,
we found out these other guys are doing
this stuff.
We got to get on the program and he
didn't want to do it.
And so by the time Lance got into the
sport,
you know,
he didn't invent doping.
I mean,
it was already ramping in,
it was full on cold coal,
full coal.
And only land stayed was like,
well,
if everybody's doing it,
we're going to do it.
We might as well do it at a really
professional level.
And uh,
you know,
that's,
that's where he sort of took it to
another level and who knows if it's
still going on.
Yeah.
I had him on the podcast and I watched
it.
Yeah,
it was,
it was very enlightening.
Um,
I like him a lot.
You know,
he's an extreme winter and extreme
winters are there.
They are the type of people that they
just push everything to the outmost
edge.
And that guy,
if everybody.
I've firmly believed that if everybody
was 100 percent natural,
there was the same results,
probably would have had probably.
Yeah,
probably would have been different
numbers as far as like the times
achieved.
But I think he's still probably would
have won it.
Probably.
Yes,
probably.
Probably is a bit.
It's a big word,
right?
Well,
and this is,
this is why it's still in a moral act
because there are people that don't do
it or they don't want to do it and we'll
never know how they would've done
compared to the people that are doping.
And um,
uh,
but again,
probably we know that all of the other
people that were on the podium with
lance for those seven years,
they all had been busted for dopey or
admitted that they doped up.
So the outcome,
you know,
how far down do you go to give the
Jersey and did 127th place guy or
something because we know so many of
them were doing it.
It's just so fascinating to me from a
perspective of these guys are
essentially experimenting with their
bodies.
Trying to find the right levels,
trying to find out what's the best
method to do so and along the entire,
you know,
the career that lance had,
you see all these adjustments that these
people are making and been trying to.
Well,
one of the early books at before all
this came out about land.
So it was called breaking the chain by
Willie who was a,
um,
a sworn your or you know,
one of the people who give massage
therapies to a or.
No,
I think it was one of the mechanics
anyway,
with,
with the uh,
uh,
Festina team.
They got busted in [inaudible] 98 and he
said basically these guys were just
experimenting randomly.
No one knew what to do.
What's the dosage?
How many days,
every other day.
How do I incorporate the other things
I'm doing?
What about food training?
It was just,
you know,
Katy bar the door.
Let's just try anything.
So again,
one of the things lance did was hire the
best doctor.
This mckelly Ferrari.
Know the business you got to knew the
most about how to do it properly and
adjust it for each body.
Because everybody's body is different.
Okay,
so we're gonna try it,
you know,
you do this for months before the big
race and figure it out and other people
weren't doing that.
And then by the time they scrambled to
catch up,
tyler talks about this in his book,
you know,
after he left the postal team and got
his own team and then of course Ferrari
wasn't available.
So we hired this other guy flint days
who screwed up and mix the bags of blood
and gave him the wrong drug.
And he got.
He got popped,
he said for what?
He was doping,
but he got popped for somebody else's
dope.
Oh,
because someone else's blood was in the
system,
correct?
Right.
I think that's what it was.
And and really vote talks about this and
breaking the chain to about one of the
guys that,
one of the early guys that got busted.
He.
Oh,
he used his mechanics urine for the
urine test,
which you store it in a little condom
that's held underneath this little fake
penis called the wizard.
Oh,
I've seen that because at the drug test
you have to look and watch the Ip
because just to make sure so you,
you do it in a way.
Just what the problem was that the
mechanic had stayed up all night working
on the bikes and took some stimulants.
Stimulants are in the year and so this
poor guy gets busted for something.
He didn't take course he was taking
something else.
Oh yeah.
There's horror stories about this guy's
putting bags of blood on the hook on
the,
in the hotel room on the wall where the
painting is that it drips down into
your,
you know,
it's like,
no,
this is,
you know,
really a,
a barbaric system when they,
in the early days when they were
experimenting.
Uh,
so again went lance did was just take it
to another level since it's going on
anyway.
We might as well do it professionally.
Okay.
And he would have gotten away with it
because had he stayed retired,
but back to where you started,
it's,
you know,
when you're at that level and you push
your body every day and you get all the
endorphins and the testosterone and the
camaraderie with the guys.
It,
it's great.
It is so fun.
I still ride four or five days a week
with the guys that I used to race with
and friends in the area here and I,
you know,
if I missed three or four days a week
traveling,
I'm just crawling out of my skin.
I just got to get back on.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
And I'm 62 years old,
so imagine your lance and you have the
highest competitive edge,
probably anybody and,
and you're a super athlete and super
gifted and then you're push,
push,
and then you've got those seven straight
and then you retire.
And then what?
Golf.
Yeah.
It doesn't have the same intensity.
And so I completely understand why so
many of these guys come back.
Remember,
Brett Farve came back a couple of times
and uh,
you know,
it's just hard to,
to,
to break that habit.
Yeah,
I see it all the time with fighters.
Unfortunately we're,
the consequences are much graver,
you know,
when you're older and your body doesn't
respond the same way and you've already
taken a lot of damage,
but yet you still have this Jonesing for
the spotlight and see them come back.
I mean,
they all have done it yet.
Sugar Ray,
Leonard,
Alia down the line and a lot of MMA
fighters have done it as well.
It's just,
it's so,
it's the life,
you know,
you get Monday morning,
I'm gonna do this workout,
I eat this and it's just a great pattern
to be and it feels great.
You're working toward this goal in six
months or this is going to happen.
And then when that goal is gone,
it's like,
well,
why?
Why am I getting up at six in the
morning to this?
I mean,
I like doing that,
but I got to have a reason.
I mean,
Atlanta stayed retired,
probably be governor of Texas by now
probably right?
So,
uh,
yeah,
but,
uh,
I mean he was so beloved when he was
doing the live strong foundation and the
whole deal of trying to help people with
cancer and,
you know,
his own struggle overcoming cancer.
It's just such a crazy story.
Well,
and it really,
the,
the meltdown,
was it part of that Omerta rule and it
works if,
if everyone has something to lose.
The problem was,
was um,
Floyd Landis,
you know,
he,
he got popped for the,
his victory in the 2006 Tour de France
for doping,
which he was.
And so he served his two years after a
long struggle of denial and so forth.
And then he wanted to come back and he,
and,
and he couldn't get hired.
And then he went to lance and said,
well,
you know,
can I be on the radio shack team?
And apparently lance said no.
And so there he is standing there with
nothing,
nothing to lose.
So that's when he went to the press and
said,
you know,
I know where the bodies are buried.
And uh,
you know,
that's where it got bad.
Remember that when that happened and
Lance Hill,
that press conference,
you know,
we like our story better than his story.
It's like wait stories.
He's got to start with just what
happened and uh,
you know,
so,
uh,
and same thing with tyler,
you know,
he had nothing left to lose.
So he,
that book the secret race,
here's what we did and uh,
that blew it all open.
So how do you get into skepticism from
there?
Well,
I was still teaching college at night
while I was doing the bike race and
stuff.
And uh,
then I,
I got burnout,
you know,
just the training and all that and
decide,
okay,
I can't do this forever.
So I went back and got my phd in the
history of science and uh,
and then I started,
I was teaching at Occidental College and
I was like,
okay,
I'm a college professor.
That's a great gig.
Uh,
it's a good life.
but,
but then we started in my garage,
skeptic magazine and the lecture series
at Caltech on science and pseudoscience
and cults and science and religion and
alternative medicine and quackery and
all this stuff.
And,
and I thought that that's an interesting
niche to have and,
and so that just got bigger and bigger.
And my first book,
uh,
white people believe where things came
out in [inaudible] 97 and at about that
time,
Occidental college is going through a
financial crisis and they were letting
go their adjuncts,
which at the time I was not on a tenure
track,
I was a full time adjunct and I could
see the writing on the wall,
okay,
this may not end up being a tenure track
job.
And the skeptic thing was getting big
and I got a big contract through my
agent for my second book.
So I thought,
okay,
I'm just going to go for it.
I'm going to be a full time writer.
And it's a little risky.
But I had already done the risky thing
of,
you know,
just dropping everything and doing the
race across America steps.
I thought,
okay,
I can do it.
And this then became really my job.
I still teach one class a semester at
Chapman,
but my main job is writing books and
running the society,
a publishing the magazine skeptic.
And it's kind of a niche market of a,
it's like my column in scientific
American.
I cover the topics in there that aren't
covered in the rest of the magazine,
like cancer quackery or like I'm working
on one now on a Charlie Sheen's a quack
cancer doctor is aids doctor.
I mean,
he's got a quack cancer or aids.
Uh,
it's eight,
sorry.
Yeah.
Uh,
he,
you know,
he is tiger blood and all that,
you know.
Well,
he doesn't have tiger.
There's no tiger blood.
Okay.
So he got HIV and so he immediately went
on the drug cocktail,
which works,
you know,
this is a miracle of modern medicine
that kind of just sort of slipped by
without anybody making a big fuss about
it,
you know,
t huge teams of medical researchers and
they figured out the right cocktail and
then you adjust it for each person and
you can,
you can't get rid of the HIV virus,
but you'd knock it down so much that it
can't,
it doesn't cause the aids,
um,
symptoms.
You get pneumonia or whatever.
And,
and so,
um,
so he did that.
But then,
much to my amazement,
he,
uh,
Bill Maher on his show a couple of weeks
ago,
I had this guy on this guy from Mexico
who has this cure for aids.
And,
uh,
if you take this,
um,
the blood of an arthritic goat,
so a goat that has arthritis,
how they determined,
I'm not sure that's allegedly charlie,
went to Mexico and,
and did the,
the arthritic goat's blood treatment and
it cured his aides.
Well,
none of this is true.
Uh,
he stopped the drug cocktail.
He went down there and stop the normal
drug cocktail for AIDS HIV and it came
roaring back.
Of course,
if you don't keep taking the drugs,
the virus starts multiplying and it
roars back in your body.
The goat,
the goat blood didn't work.
And then he came home and went back on
the drug cocktail and he's fine now.
So he went down there to actually do
this.
He went down there to do this.
Well,
because he was probably told,
well,
he's probably scared.
I don't know.
But,
uh,
this is what I understand.
If there's already a drug cocktail that
absolutely works,
why would you want to stay just to
prevent the aids symptoms from coming on
from you getting the diseases you still
had the HIV virus like magic knock it
down to an almost undetectable level.
Yeah,
that's correct.
And that's should be good enough.
Well that's what Magic Johnson.
So it doesn't even show up in this.
That's right,
right.
Like if he gets tested right now he's
HIV positive or a negative.
Right?
Right.
That's right.
Yup.
Even though they don't guarantee it just
in case it's hiding in the nooks and
crannies of your nervous system or
wherever.
Um,
so,
um,
yeah,
so that's,
you know,
that's the kind of thing that scientific
American would normally cover,
but we would cover or conspiracy
theories like the nine slash 11 truth
is,
you know,
uh,
what about the free fall of the
buildings and the puffs of smoke and the
this and that.
You know,
some of these are empirical questions we
can get at that,
that normal science journals wouldn't
cover that we cover.
So skeptic has kind of a niche market
for fringe claims.
Borderlands claims,
you know,
like,
like scientific American deals a lot
with global climate change,
but they don't deal with the global
warming deniers.
Who are these people,
what are their arguments?
So we would take on that and go,
okay,
here's their 10 arguments,
the best arguments they have,
and then here's the answers of how we
know global warming is real,
how do you know it's human cause how do
we know these things are normal science
journalists don't have to deal with
that.
They are already down the path.
And I'm like okay,
what are we going to do about it?
And that sort of thing.
So that's kind of our specialty.
Well it's an important resource because
whether it's global warming or nine
slash 11 truther and there's just,
there's so much confusion out there when
it comes to trying to figure out what's
real and what's not real.
Someone sends you a link,
you know like what is this?
And it's a youtube video.
You go to the youtube,
you are being lied to.
What the Hell is going on?
What you don't know what's going on.
And then you watch it,
like global warming is just one of the
many ones that,
uh,
that confuse the shit out of people.
And then,
you know,
then you find out that there's companies
that actually have a vested interest in
confusing people.
Like,
have you ever seen that documentary
merchants of doubt?
I'm in it.
Oh,
that's right.
Yes.
I'm in it.
Yeah.
I asking you that many documentaries
officially to that,
the beauty of that,
a film made by a candidate that is now a
friend of mine.
It was very clever because,
um,
he tracked down the same scientists who
were hired by the tobacco companies.
Not just the same arguments,
you know,
planting a seed.
Some of the times the same people paid
by these front groups and they'd know
how to do it through.
It's so theatrical the way they present
their arguments.
It's one of the reasons why I've always
hated those.
Those tough television shows where you
have a,
you know,
a,
a host,
and then you have the split window.
One person talking over them on this
side and one person is on the left,
one person isn't the right,
literally and figuratively.
Right?
They're yelling at each other and you
never get anything done.
You never figured out anything.
But the person who's better at
expressing that opinion in a real quick,
you know,
three or four minute soundbite of
interview,
they get their argument across and
that's what these merchants of doubt
guys were doing.
That's right.
Yep.
They got the sound bites.
Uh,
the science is not all in the jury is
still out.
What jury,
where you know it.
It's almost like there's a science are
that calls all the shots.
And if we can just find out what's going
on there,
we're going to put us,
you know,
we're going to blow this stuff that
isn't how it works.
There's 10,000
climate scientists working in all these
labs and their findings converge to the
same conclusion.
So for there to be conspiracy,
they'd all have to be meeting on the
weekends going,
okay,
I'm going to say that the,
you know,
the parts per million of this particular
gas is this,
what are you going to say?
This is not how it works.
It's a very competitive enterprise.
If you want to make a name for yourself
and you're a young scientist just
debunking one of these arguments about
tree ring data or the ice core data,
which would be huge.
And they try it,
you know,
it's like the people saying,
Einstein was wrong.
Well,
okay,
there's been 100 years of scientists
testing Einstein.
If he was wrong,
we would know by now,
oh no,
they all,
they're all conspiring to cover the
truth.
No,
that isn't how it works.
There's also this appeal or this,
this,
this.
For some reason people are drawn to this
idea of being a no nonsense person.
You know the no nonsense person.
You believe in Al Gore,
you believe that you have,
if you've seen an inconvenient truth and
then.
But I find that when I talked to these
people that like really dismiss global
climate change or dismiss a lot of
people's concerns about those things,
they haven't really researched it that
much.
There so definitive on their ideas,
but they haven't really researched it
that much,
but they don't want to be a fool.
That seems to be a lot of the appeal to
them to take this hard stance.
It's like they don't want to be one of
those fools.
What do you hippie?
Yeah.
By buy of that nonsense.
It's,
it,
it's partly that,
like one of the appeals of conspiracy
theories is,
you know,
we're going to blow the lid off and I'm
not being fooled by the,
I know the Bush administration light and
as yet.
And we're going to.
Yeah.
So I mean that's one of the appeals of
the nine slash 11 truth movement is
that,
you know,
we know what really happened and,
and you know,
Bush lied,
okay,
well maybe lied about this little thing
or maybe it was misdirection or get bad
information.
But the idea of orchestrating an entire
event like nine slash 11 and
coordinating the flying of the planes
into buildings and you know,
what did they do with the passengers and
how did get the people into the World
Trade Center buildings to break open the
drywall and plant the explosive devices
without anybody noticing how many
thousands of people would have to be
involved.
You think the federal government could
pull it off?
Something like that when they couldn't
even do Watergate.
I mean,
here it's just a hotel.
Break it.
I forgot to bring in a book for.
You.
Damn it.
I have a doctorate.
He's sort of a doctor is really a weed
doctor is a doctor that prescribes my
medical marijuana.
I get headaches.
Getting one right now.
Anyway,
he gave me this book when I went to
visit him and it was a book about Tesla
Technology that was used to take down
the twin towers.
Oh,
I don't know this sitting in the
doctor's office,
boy.
Oh,
he's fucking telling me about this
technology.
That what,
what,
what?
Have you ever seen the turns concrete
into dust,
right?
Well,
you know,
concretes,
it starts out as powder talking about
millions of tons of,
of a building that's compressed and
falling down.
Yeah.
I would imagine there'd be a bunch of
dust for awhile.
Thermite was the big thing there.
Might will melt the.
Okay.
So then there were tests done and the
thermite and it doesn't burn hot enough
to get through a whole huge beam.
Okay.
Well they have I think just cut through
an engine block with that stuff though,
right?
Yeah.
But these beams are like,
you know,
the size of this table,
but if it had a lot of thermite well
but.
So then they say,
well it's super thermite.
Well it's like,
well where is this super thermal?
I never heard of it.
Well it's secret super secret.
Super thermite pieces of evidence that
they were using or like the cuts,
the angular cuts on the beams.
Well that was actually done after the
buildings had color.
Right.
They were trying to clean it up.
They had to cut some of them down and so
they were using these photos.
So there was a lot of confusion.
Okay,
you sit.
But the thing is,
you don't need to know anything about
thermite or tesla technology.
We know that the planes hit the
buildings.
You can see it on video,
you could see which floors they were at,
the angle of the wings and so forth for
that to have happened.
And explosive devices planted at the
exact floors where they knew ahead of
time what floors and what angle.
The plane right there stop.
Full Stop,
you know,
that can't be well,
it's very,
very,
very unlikely.
Super Unlikely not to mention a g Gordon
Liddy once told me about Watergate,
the,
you know,
the competency problem and the,
and the people can't keep their mouth
shut problem,
you know,
uh,
the more people you have involved,
the more they're going to screw up or
chicken out or change their mind or then
tell their friends and lovers and so
forth.
You know,
I know the guy that did it and pretty
soon they're on your show telling about
what they saw Haka.
No one's come out to say,
you know,
I was sitting there in my office and I
saw these guys breaking through the dry
wall.
And putting these things inside that you
know,
so I mean someone like Jesse Ventura
thing,
so it was all done under the cover of a,
of a fixing the elevators in the world
trade center,
fixing the elevators.
I mean this would have had to gone for
weeks and weeks and I don't
know if Jesse Ventura really believes
that.
He says this,
he's selling conspiracy.
Now I have A.
There's a bunch of people that
conspiracy becomes a business and like
Alex Jones,
who's a friend of mine and he's out of
his fucking mind.
I know he believes this stuff.
Or does he just say stuff?
Just to see what comes out.
He believes a lot,
but he gets a lot of things right.
That's what's unfortunate.
The unfortunate thing about conspiracies
is that it's not all cut and dry.
There was things like operation
northwoods where the government really
did plan on orchestrating these
artificial attacks,
arming Cuban friendlies a bay.
They're going to blow up a jetliner and
blaming on Cuba.
There were real actual conspiring or con
conspiracies that we can prove.
This is the problem with the nine slash
11.
Truth is,
or the extreme conspiracy theories,
they're missing where the real action
is,
you know,
all those third world dictators we were
supporting in the seventies under
Kissinger and Nixon,
all real.
This stuff happened and that's it.
It's not as sexy as,
you know,
taking over the world are running the
world economy,
but it's,
it's real and it's affected over in
north.
I mean,
remember that,
I mean the,
when,
when that was going on with the ads,
that conspiracy,
that's a real conspiracy.
There's a real,
there's real ones,
you know.
And then there was a real one that was
apparently being planned by Dick Cheney
on the way out.
You know,
they were planning on doing something
with Iran.
They were planning on some sort of a
false flag.
But when people look at operation
northwoods and they look at that where
it would have cost American lives,
they had a real conspiracy that
President Kennedy vetoed.
That was actually signed by the Joint
Chiefs of staff that gets,
it gets the Bay of pigs.
That was a conspiracy.
Yeah.
So there,
there have been real conspiracy,
right?
So they look at nine slash 11,
they go,
this is the grand one,
the big one,
right?
So how can we tell the difference
between the real ones that.
Well,
okay,
well,
so there's certain criteria.
Again,
the grander the theory is,
the less likely it is a real conspiracy,
global domination running the world's
economy,
these sorts of things.
Well,
how about the big Alex Jones one?
They want to cut the population down to
like 500 million people worldwide.
Yeah.
Well that,
that could,
that could happen naturally if we just,
uh,
educated women made them economically
empowered and had access to birth
control,
you know,
that's the solution to they
overpopulation.
You really think that would work.
People still want babies.
Well,
they do,
yes,
of course.
But the replacement level,
there are a number of countries below
the replacement level and we know what
the factors are,
the things I just said,
you know,
just being,
being a prosperous democracy in which
women had the franchise and they're
economically empowered and educated and
they have access to birth control.
Family planning happens naturally.
You don't have to do the China one child
rule,
you don't have to do that.
It happens naturally.
So if you're,
if you're a pro life,
so called pro life and you're against
abortion,
that and you want to reduce the amount
of abortions,
just educate women and giving them power
and give them choice and access to birth
control and it happens naturally.
Yeah,
that's a weird statistic,
isn't
it?
That the more prosperous cities become,
the more the civilization becomes
advanced as far as like education and
technology.
You get less birth rate.
That's right.
So it's [inaudible] Uzi and malthus was
wrong.
And,
and,
and Paul Ehrlich with the population
bomb wrong and they're still modern.
Neil Matthews that are claiming this
today,
you know,
the club of Rome,
the limits of growth and all this stuff.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
if you want to get a population lower,
just make the people super prosperous,
especially the women.
And it just happens naturally.
And the reason is because one reason
people have so many babies in poor
countries is because they're not likely
to survive the debate.
The babies die.
And so you got to have lots of them to
get your jeans out there,
so to speak.
So it's sort of a biological impulse.
And then also to take care of you when
you're old,
you better,
you better have six or 10 just to make
sure there's a couple left when year old
to support you.
You don't need to do any of that when
you have a prosperous economy.
The effect
though is it's so scary as far as the
overpopulation effect,
when we look at the raw numbers from
like 1970 versus 2016 worldwide,
but it's not that long ago in our
lifetime while I was alive,
the population has more than doubled.
And in the United States,
just in the United States.
And forget about poor countries.
We've got about China.
Forget about India,
you know?
Yes,
correct.
Correct.
So there's,
you know,
as the population pig works its way
through the python demographic,
python,
it's going to take a while to catch up.
So already country,
there's a number of countries that are
below replacement level,
but what countries are below that?
Well,
Japan,
Sweden,
Russia.
Uh,
I don't know.
There's at least a dozen in mostly
northern European countries and that
means that their population is still
growing by the momentum of past decades,
but the current generation will have,
you know,
one point nine children on average.
Two point one is the replacement level
and I forget how many kinds of 20
something countries are below two point
one replacement level,
but it'll take till about 20 slash 50
before we see the topping off of the
population growth and then start to go
back down.
It's one reason you almost never see the
curves after 20 slash 50 because if
you're a pro environmentalist or pr pro,
anti population organization,
you don't want to show the good news
from 2050 to 2100,
but the UN two of the three you and
projections,
they have like a conservative middle and
in and then I'm more radical projections
and that by 2100,
the modest middle one shows us back down
to around probably six or 7 billion from
will hit a peak of nine or 10 billion in
2050 back down to where we are now in
2100.
And then by 2100,
maybe one or 2 billion,
if,
Yep,
it could down to one or two that this
could happen just by if.
I mean there's so many variables,
it's hard to predict,
but that could happen if everybody is
prosperous,
particularly Africa.
So one of the things the gates
foundation is trying to do is just solve
certain basic,
simple problems.
And,
and the UN is trying to get rid of these
corrupt governments.
That's what's holding them back.
There's enough food to feed 7 billion
people.
It's the distribution.
That's the problem.
The Green Revolution,
Norman Borlaug and the green revolution
salt,
you know,
we have the technology to do at Gmos are
good for feeding poor people.
I'm a sub,
but it's the corrupt dictatorships that
prevent the distribution of the food and
resources and keeps the population from
being prosperous so they have more
children.
So that,
in my opinion,
that's the longterm solution.
So there's two things there.
One,
there's the conspiracy by the elites to
hide the fact that we're going to get
down to 2 billion people by 2100.
We got that.
Well,
it's the environmentalist,
they're hiding it hit,
we don't know for sure this is going to
happen.
These are projections,
but then there's also the food
distribution,
a conversation,
which is a very fascinating one.
You know,
I had these guys on from the documentary
cowspiracy,
which is well intended,
but apparently got a bunch of stuff
wrong about how many acres it takes to
have a cow graze,
like how much I'm going to,
what are the requirements and what you
can do with veganism versus what it was.
Essentially they were really heavily
biased and promoting a vegan lifestyle,
which is their choice.
You know,
they could do that,
but that's the big argument today.
It's like,
do we have enough land?
Do we have enough resources to feed all
the people?
My conversation has always been like,
okay,
are we doing it right now?
Yes,
we're all eating right,
especially the United States.
Okay,
well you know,
we are running out of land.
We are running out of food.
We are running out of this.
The Sky is falling,
but are okay.
Are we doing it right now?
Are we feeding ourselves right now?
We are right,
you are really easily,
in fact,
problem.
We have a surplus,
plenty of food.
Not to say that a lot of the methods
we're using aren't disgusting.
Like factory farming.
Farming is terrible,
horrible and the,
and then a lot of laws to protect them
or disgusting to like the Ag gag laws.
Those are viable,
but why can't we keep doing it?
And then then the argument kind of falls
apart.
Well we were gonna we're gonna run out
of stuff.
Well,
okay.
So in the long run we want to get off
the factory farming.
It is according to disgusting habit.
And the poly farms,
you know,
the happy,
I call them the happy farms,
you know,
wherever Joel Salatin,
every cow has a name and there's the
happy chicken running around.
Yeah,
that gets killed that yeah,
he has a great life until that last day.
So yeah,
those kinds of farms cannot support 7
billion people.
So in the long run we have to get the
numbers down somewhat.
And also the technology of synthetic
meat,
we just getting there.
It's a,
you know,
I think we're not five years away.
I think,
you know,
we're,
we're maybe a couple of decades away.
You don't think it's possible to get a
significant number of the people in this
country to go vegan?
No,
I don't think that's gonna happen in the
moral arc.
I have a chapter on animal rights in
which I show that the numbers are still
in single digits or even with all the
environmental movement and all the,
you
know,
vegetarian,
pro,
vegetarian.
It's still less than 10 percent.
It's more like six or seven percent of
the population,
the population in the United States.
And so I liked the reduce attarian
movements and new word reduce attarian
let's just,
you know,
meatless Mondays just just cut it down
and try to,
you know,
if you shop at whole foods,
get the happy farm meat,
you know,
that sort of thing.
Um,
you know,
obviously if you can afford a whole
foods,
I know it's not okay.
So in the long run,
you know,
markets will drive down prices of say a
synthetic meat.
Right now,
you know,
a little patty made out of stem cells is
thousand dollars,
but you know,
that course,
that's what computers were in the
forties.
And so now look,
and then this will happen,
but not in five years or 10 years.
And so the idea of like,
well in the meantime,
let's get everybody to go vegan.
This isn't also isn't going to happen.
Why you,
why don't you think it's going to
happen?
Uh,
I think first of all,
we,
we have a habit of eating meat.
It tastes great.
Most people like it.
Uh,
you,
you can get your protein from other
sources.
I don't think that's a viable argument
anymore,
but,
but most people,
they just like it and it's culturally
has still has a lot of momentum.
I think it's one thing to get people to
care about global warming or yeah,
let's drive electric cars,
whatever.
You don't have to give up something
that,
that you really,
really like,
but food,
people really like their meat.
And uh,
I,
I would be okay if everybody went that
way,
but I'm not quite there yet myself.
I still have meat now and then,
but I've,
I've reduced it considerably compared to
before was the ethical considerations of
the reason why people think that it's a
good way to go and not,
not necessarily protein wise or.
I mean there's,
there's a,
there's a bunch of people that argue
that the,
it's very difficult to get the same
amount of protein,
but then there's also people that argue
that you really don't need the amount of
protein the most people consume anyway.
Right.
Well,
you can try to change behavior.
Okay.
Nudge people with incentives,
but why not also go the path of the
technological solutions,
synthetic meat,
you know,
people are working on this,
there are companies doing it,
you know,
funded by a venture capitalists in
Google.
One of the google x projects is to do
this.
Again,
I think it's,
you know,
it's maybe it's like self driving cars
know it's just,
it's going to take a few decades before
everybody is there,
but I'm optimistic because we're at
least moving in that direction.
Yeah.
I think that's a real possibility of
headless animals that we've engineered
and the labs and that's where we get our
food from.
But what will it be as good for you?
Well,
it tastes as good.
Well that a principle that should just
be a scientific western.
Right?
We know what,
what's in inmate.
Okay.
So just put it in there.
And your synthetic meat,
just design it with your designer jeans,
I guess.
I mean,
but there's a big difference between
cows that eat certain diets versus cows
eat grass fed cows versus health wise.
As far as the,
uh,
there was a study that was released
recently showing the benefits of grass
fed beef versus
corn fed beef just health wise.
Yep.
So,
you know,
I don't know.
We'll see.
Yeah.
Because I'm curious.
I mean if they do create synthetic meat,
will,
will it have the same properties?
I,
I would imagine you could even build in
marbling,
just put fat cells in there to make it
juicy or something.
And maybe that won't be as healthy,
but maybe you think,
well I don't care.
Yeah.
But I would be,
you know,
I mean,
there's a difference between the way it
tastes like a marble,
like a fat from a grass fed cow versus
the fat from a corn fed cow versus a fat
from a lab built cow going to be yet
it's also just habit of what you used
to.
I love red meat,
but I almost never eat it anymore.
I really don't miss it.
Uh,
you just kind of get into the pattern of
change in your diet and it,
I think,
I think we could get there.
I just don't think that that's the only
avenue to solving the factory farming
problem.
I think lowering the population,
synthetic meat,
changing behavior,
just come at it from a bunch of
different angles.
Um,
that's of the case with every problem,
right?
Absolutely.
So I call that,
I call it in the moral of that Protopian
solutions.
Uh,
Kevin Kelly,
the founder of wired magazine,
he used this term protopia small
changes,
tiny little bit of progress.
It's like last year's nab system,
uh,
and this year's Nav system in your car,
this one slightly better.
It has this little feature and this
little thing,
you know,
and,
and over many years and decades,
all of a sudden you've got a super smart
car versus the Jalopies of the fifties,
not a flying car.
You don't go from,
you know,
the Jalopy to the flying car and one
year you go to what we have now
incrementally.
And that's true in all technologies.
You know,
it's like the Mac just keeps,
you know,
I've been buying Max for,
25 years.
He since the late eighties and it's a 30
and a,
it's the same pay,
the same price.
You have to,
you got 2,400
bucks,
you get pretty much the same.
Double the computer for the same price
every three years.
And that's what most technologies go
through.
Yeah.
Well I think that's one of the cool
things about following it.
You know,
one of the things that's so fascinating
to me about following technology is like
woo,
Samsung has the new galaxy s nine.
It's waterproof and it can show the moon
these days are there.
They're so interesting to see where this
innovation is going and when the
innovation is,
you know,
when it's things like mean essentially
I've made the argument that the view
leaf cell phones alone,
if everyone's making cell phones right
now,
so let's just make the same cell phone
forever.
We're good.
You know,
you have an iphone six s leave it there.
We don't need any more innovation.
Let's use that for,
for other things mean we'd probably be
pretty happy.
We'd be all right.
But you know,
that's not how companies working now,
but we're fascinated by innovation.
We actually,
I'm a little mad at apple right now
because the new o s system,
I lost half my music.
I don't know where it went and I haven't
taken the time to figure out how to get
it back.
And what do you mean?
Oh,
it's not on your phone and the cloud he
has.
They're encouraging use of the cloud.
Yeah,
yeah.
You could say guys,
whatever.
It was great.
Just okay,
but that that mean there
is a lot of nonsense that they do when
they update things,
but that's also because they're trying
to build in new features and their
planning several steps ahead for the
future.
They want everything to be in the cloud,
which is kind of weird.
Another thing,
electric cars,
I think you go to the Petersen Museum
here and you see electric cars in the 19
twenties happened,
conspiracy kind of oil companies,
tire company.
You ever see the documentary who killed
the electric car?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's like we should have.
We should be there now.
You should have been there decades ago
then about the fact that Henry Ford's
first car,
the fenders were made out of hemp and
you know that.
I've never seen it.
No.
I'll show you a video of them because
it's really fascinating and pull up
Henry Ford first car hamp.
They used hemp fibers too,
by the way,
was legal back then know it wasn't
illegal until they came up with a thing
called the decorticator,
which will allow them to effectively
process hemp fiber.
That's when William Randolph hearst
started this propaganda against hemp.
That was era.
Yeah.
That's how marijuana became illegal.
It had nothing to do with the drug.
The psychoactive aspect of it had to do
with the the textiles and using it as
paper and using it as a commodity.
That's when it became illegal and it was
all hearst.
William Randolph hearst was a
motherfucker.
Really?
Yeah.
So this car is actually made out of
hemp.
The fenders and Lotus did one recently
where they had an exposed hood.
But what's interesting about this,
we see it a Henry Ford,
I don't know if it's this video,
but he hit it.
He hit him with a hammer.
Oh Wow.
I mean incredibly durable.
Hemp is an amazing,
amazing plant.
I don't know if you've ever picked up a
hemp stock,
but it's incredibly hard,
but really light,
like very,
very different than any other would
like.
It's hard like a walnut.
Right?
But it's light like a Balsa Wood.
It's very,
very strange.
It's a very unusual car.
Pull up the Lotus because it was real
recent,
like last year to my car.
Exactly.
It would bend like crazy.
It's lighter and stronger than steel,
which is insane.
Right.
And you know,
the whole thing with how to drugs become
illegal.
That's a kind of a concern,
you know,
sort of a conspiracy is a real
conspiracy because hemp is non
psychoactive.
The fact that it's still illegal.
I mean they're just now starting to grow
it in America.
We sell him my company on it sells hemp
protein,
which is legal.
Non-Psychoactive doesn't have any thc in
it.
We had a buyer from Canada.
Really see this right here.
This is the new,
um,
Lotus that is the entire roof if they
show it and see if you could find a
picture where they show the actual car
itself,
Jamie,
but it's a,
these,
all these panels are made out of hemp
and like it's insanely light.
Yeah.
But if you show the actual car itself,
Jamie,
you can see maybe go to the front,
the,
the beginning of the video.
You could see the actual hood of the
car.
It's exposed.
Okay.
So they may,
they essentially made a giant percentage
of the car out of hemp,
including the seats that looks,
that looks lighter than carbon fibers.
Hey,
I wonder if anyone's made a hemp
bicycle.
That's a good question because that,
you know,
that's the whole thing about carbon
fibers.
So lightweight but strong.
So if what you were saying about him is
true,
there should be heavy bikes on a lot of
other light things like bows and things
along those lines.
I think that,
uh,
that's a real conspiracy conspiracy
back,
Wayne.
There's a reason why,
you know,
Orson Welles made that movie citizen
Kane Bout William Randolph hearst and
insanely,
insanely powerful and influential man
who didn't really use that influence in
the best way for society.
Did it Tuesday he had paper mills and he
didn't want to convert his paper into
hemp paper and paper was far superior,
but it would have cost them millions of
dollars because he had forests and so
popular science magazine back then and
see if he could find this color.
It was a hemp,
the new billion dollar crop.
A bicycle from him.
There you go.
Done.
Yeah,
that's a good looking bike.
Okay.
Yeah,
there you go.
I have a carbon fiber bike.
Maybe I'll have to start looking at
that.
Yeah,
I don't know where you buy one of those.
Um,
why is there no thc in the hip,
in the,
a female plants in the,
in the flower.
Okay.
It's in the flower buds.
That's the female is the one you get
high off of the mail,
but your,
which one is the stock of it?
You're not looking for flowers,
so when you're using it to make things
right,
but uh,
the seeds but hemp,
it's on the cover of the,
uh,
of popular science from like way back
then it looks like about 19 thirties or
forties.
Yeah,
well I believe it was,
I want to say 30.
It was 33 or something like that,
or 35 when it was made illegal.
And uh,
they made it illegal and they were
calling it marijuana,
which is really interesting.
Which is a slang for a Mexican wild
tobacco.
It's not even cannabis.
So when they were making marijuana
illegal,
they didn't even know that they were
making hemp illegal.
It was very tricky the way they did it.
They,
they made these articles,
they printed all these articles about
Mexicans and blacks raping white women
because they were high on this new drug.
Right.
That's also what funded reefer madness,
which I'm sure you've seen it all those.
Those are real conspiracies.
Absolutely.
And that's people that had a vested
financial interest in making something
illegal,
a commodity.
It's so crazy because the fact that
marijuana or the cannabis plant is so
versatile,
it,
there's so many different things.
They figured out a way to attack one
aspect of it and demonize the entire
plant and then eliminate competition
right now because it makes a far
superior paper,
far superior cloth.
It's like incredibly durable.
Like the paper,
if you ever had hemp paper in front of
you,
it feels like a regular piece of paper,
but it's really hard to tear.
It's a really interesting job.
Money out of that.
Exactly.
Well,
what do they make money out of now?
it's in fiber.
Yeah.
So,
well,
and there's,
there was a documentary on about the,
uh,
public transportation system here in La
that was quite extensive at the thirties
with the,
you know,
electric,
electric trolleys and this stuff and
they all got ripped out and torn down
and the cars were burned and so on,
just because the automobile industry and
the oil industry wanted it,
you know,
it's like La should be a car down entire
country,
should be a car culture rather than a
public transportation culture.
My wife's from Cologne,
Germany,
public transportation in Europe is
fantastic.
You really don't need a car for except
for rare occasions here when she moved
here to be with me.
It's like,
oh,
got to have a car.
He can't get anywhere.
And uh,
again,
that's kind of a conspiracy and that's,
those are the kinds of things we should
be focusing on.
And talking about.
Uh,
I think the war on drugs,
I mean,
I don't call it a conspiracy,
but you know,
it's over.
It's been over for decades.
That's,
it's also so blatant that it's only the
war on some drugs.
Yes.
It's not like we're trying to keep
everyone's sober,
we're just gonna sell sanctioned drugs
that have tax codes,
you know,
and that's,
that's really what the war is on drugs
that you can't control and tax and it's
so blatant and obvious,
right?
It might not treat it like an industry,
like any alcohol industry.
Sure,
absolutely.
Yep.
Like alcohol,
alcohol's,
and unbelievably devastating drug and
readily available almost everywhere.
We've got enough in that back room to
kill you.
If you want to kill yourself.
Drink right now while the show was going
on.
We went in the next hour,
you'll be dead.
It'll be amazing.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
And mentally and no one cares.
Like everybody would go,
wow.
Michael Shermer drank himself to death.
Oh,
poor guy.
You know what I mean?
It's not like,
Oh man,
he did drugs and he had an old.
Wow,
that's so tragic.
Drugs are awful,
right?
While they're everywhere,
every street you go down,
you pass by liquor stores and
restaurants that sell just molecules in
your brain and your body.
Uh,
so what's the difference?
Well,
there's an,
there's absolutely real legitimate
conspiracies and I do agree with you
that those are the ones to focus on,
but they're not sexy,
sexy ones or Ufo or bigfoot.
Yeah,
that kind of stuff.
Yep.
Global diamond.
Yes.
I did this show for the Scifi channel
called Joe Rogan questions.
Everything around her that.
Yes.
Yeah.
I went around and I talked to experts,
believers,
nonbelievers,
scientists,
all these different people about a bunch
of different subjects and boy,
my desire to do that show before I
started doing it was very high and my
desire to completely avoid any,
any of that nonsense towards the end of
the show was it was almost like I
couldn't do it anymore because I had
already recognized what was going on in
so many of these cases that I was like,
this is just a bunch of people that want
to believe they have these ideas in
their head and they want to chase these
ideas down,
whether it's big foot or whether it's
UFO and they're not being objective even
remotely.
The vast majority of the people that are
a part of the movement or the community
that like researches,
ghosts or research is bigfoot or
researchers.
Nice people.
They're not that,
but the way they're looking at it right
is the same.
It's the same whether it's bigfoot
or chem trails or Ufo or they.
They're not.
They're not being objective.
They're going,
well,
maybe this.
What about that?
We'll have we considered this?
Nope.
They're just going.
We know the evidence is out there.
The government has been hiding extra
terrestrial life in this country.
Like where,
where,
where's the government?
Where's,
where's the government doing this?
Where's the evidence?
We know from surveys that if you tick
the box that you believe in aliens or
whatever,
you'll tick all the boxes.
Psychics.
Exactly the whole thing.
Yeah.
So there's a certain personality that
gravitates toward those kinds of beliefs
and then,
and then buys the whole thing.
Even when their contract,
they contradict each other,
like people that were,
uh,
that believed that Princess di was
murdered.
Also are morally inclined to say she
faked her death and is still alive
somewhere.
She was hanging out with Tupac.
Yeah,
they can't both be true,
but again,
there's,
so with this,
there's some cognitive dissonance that
we want a balance between the size of
the event and the size of the cars.
So I think,
uh,
you know,
the Holocaust,
one of the worst thing that's ever
happened,
whereas genocide ever conducted by one
of the worst regime,
political regimes in human history,
so there's kind of a balance there,
but if you haven't like jfk,
you know,
the leader of the free world,
powerful,
articulate,
handsome,
and so on.
And he's brought down by who,
Lee Harvey Oswald,
some lone nut,
this loser,
you know,
there's a.
So you've got a pile on the,
you know,
the,
the mafia and the CIA and he wold acted
alone.
Yeah,
I do.
Absolutely.
No question.
Why do you think that?
Well,
first of all,
there's a ton of evidence that he did do
it.
And most of the JFK conspiracy people
also agree he was involved.
He,
that he was one of the shooters.
It's one that they think there's more
than one shooter,
but so we have lots of evidence that he
did it.
You know,
we have his rifle,
we have the paper trail of what he
bought the rifle.
His fingerprints are on the rifle that
was found in the fingerprints found
several days after they found that they
had it right away too.
Is a lot of stuff with that.
So when you go to appearance,
he though that's really slippery.
Well,
okay,
so here's one of the things that
happens.
The moment something takes on great
significance.
Our mind focuses on little anomalies.
Like why was there that guy in Dealey
Plaza with the umbrella?
It's a sunny day.
It's not going to rain set.
Okay.
So he was out there protesting,
you know,
decades later they've tracked this guy
down.
He was called the umbrella man.
It's like the cigarette smoking man on x
files,
like,
Ooh,
who is the umbrella man and that the
umbrella must have been a gun and so
forth.
And he said,
no,
this is a leftover from world war
chamberlain and in his umbrella.
And he sold out to Hitler.
And that,
so the umbrella became a protest against
government,
whatever,
and so he was protesting Kennedy with
his umbrella.
And uh,
so that's.
So that's a typical thing.
Who Cares if somebody has an umbrella on
a sunny day,
whatever.
It seems like a silly thing,
but the moment something big happens.
Okay.
What is the meaning of that?
I've never even heard of that umbrella
guy,
but I have researched.
Did you ever read David Lifton's book of
Yes to evidence?
Yeah.
That's pretty fascinating.
But,
but Vincent Bugliosi,
he dressed all of those claims is last.
One of his last books was a case closed
now.
That was Gerald Posner,
also a good book whose book it was,
like a restoring history or something
like that.
It's big massive thing.
He did a shorter version and uh,
but he lined up all those claims,
you know,
like one of them was that I had it as
well get a job at the book depository
building that was right on the parade
route and he's going to turn right in
front of it.
There's Kennedy.
He must have known he was planted there
by operatives that knew this was going.
No.
So,
uh,
I think it was posner who track track
down when the White House determined
that Kennedy was even going to go to
Dallas and then months later the parade
route is determined.
Just,
you know,
just before we went.
And Oswald had that job there months
before.
It was just pure chance.
Randomness.
So much of human history turns on random
events.
It's like the assassination of Franz
Ferdinand had triggered the first world
war.
This was a conspiracy.
There were seven operatives of the black
hand,
which was this Serbian nationalist
organization and they wanted to
assassinate the archduke Franz
Ferdinand.
Okay.
So,
and we know what the,
you know,
they went to this house to get the
weapon and that has to get the grenade
and the rifle and they,
you,
you stand on this corner,
I'm going to be over there.
And this is typically how it goes.
A couple of them,
chicken that somebody did,
that,
they went to the house,
the person wasn't there to give them
their weapon,
cause there's like three of them left
and then one of them through the hand
grenade,
it bounced off the car and went under
another car and damage that car,
but not the car.
And then to the whole thing was bungled
and,
and off he went and uh,
and he gave a speech and then he decided
to go back to the hospital to visit the
people that were hurt and that and the
trailing car.
And they took the parade route back
backwards on the course.
And there's this guy,
prince eps sitting there on the curb,
despondent like,
well that was a screw up and here comes
the archduke ban.
What was a little more complicated than
that?
In fact,
the car stalled out because the cars
back then were really bad at going in
reverse.
Right?
So he was trying to put the car in
reverse.
The driver of the car is putting it in
It was convertible,
right?
Yup.
He's putting it in reverse.
The car stalled out.
And at that moment,
a guy was coming out of a store or a
restaurant where he had a sandwich
because they had something to eat after
it was over,
literally walked out.
He was right there and shot him and shot
his wife.
So that's typically conspiracies that
definitely can happen.
And obviously if Oswald had that job,
you know long in advance,
it shows before they have planned that
out.
It showed that there's a lot of
randomness involved at Lincoln
assassination.
That was a conspiracy.
They were going to assassinate the vice
president,
vice president,
secretary of state,
secretary of war,
and they had all the guys going to do
this and they all screwed up in.
The only one that succeeded was booth.
But we knew that there was a conspiracy
within hours.
And then within days they got the whole
thing.
Where are the people that did this to
Kennedy or nine slash 11.
Who were the other operatives?
Who is it?
Who did it?
Well,
wasn't there a some deathbed confessions
from.
What was his name hunt.
Was that the.
That
guy that they have photos of him that he
was arrested at the scene of the crime.
You remember the Hobos that were
arrested,
that were behind the grassy knoll and
there was so many people that called
that said that they had heard shots from
the grassy knoll.
There's more than one that's possible
because there was an echoing effect.
If you go to Dealey Plaza,
it's surprisingly small and our magic.
It's weird when you see.
Yeah,
and you know there's a museum now on the
sixth floor of the book.
You can look right out the window and
you can see the x on the street.
First shot,
second shot,
Howard Hunt,
Howard.
Confessions of Howard Hunt know that he
had said that on his deathbed he was a
CIA spy,
and on his deathbed he obviously can fit
convicted Watergate conspirators.
And he said that he was involved in the
assassination.
He said that on his deathbed he talked
about how he's an active participant.
Yes.
Okay.
Well then,
I don't know,
I don't know this particular one,
but why would you.
Why would you like be so quick to think
that more people weren't involved until
I was open to the possibility.
I mean,
we did this issue of skeptic,
you know,
on the 50 years later,
um,
what,
what clothes were closed?
It was that bookcase closed.
Uh,
and then just one book.
Well,
and then Boleo sees book.
I started reading,
you know,
just here's the claim,
here's the explanation here.
Hundreds of things.
Did they cover hunt?
I don't,
I don't remember it probably.
Did they,
how do they cover the fact that the
magic bullet theory was concocted
because they had to account for a bullet
that hit a curb under the overpass.
You know that,
right?
Yeah.
But you know,
Nova did a whole two hour special on the
magic bullet and you know,
the seats are not lined up.
They're like this.
It didn't have to make a right turn,
left turn kind of thing.
Yeah.
That's.
I mean,
look,
I've,
I hunt and I shoot guns and bullets do
weird things.
When they hit things,
they ricochet off stuff and they go left
and they go,
right?
They go all over the place.
It's you,
the idea that you are going to act to
accurately determine when someone shoots
someone and hits bone where that
bullet's going to go next is crazy.
They do weird things,
right.
You know,
they come out of people's heads.
Sometimes you shoot someone in the front
and it had come out the top of their
head.
It doesn't make any sense.
Right?
Um,
but what doesn't make sense more than
that is the pristine condition of that
bullet after shattering bone.
Well,
it wasn't a pristine.
It was squished and compared to a bullet
that's hit bone,
there's like they've shot,
I'm pretty sure it was another one
that's shot through the jail.
And then also your shot through Joe Shit
shot bone.
It was shattered.
They've never been able to recreate the
get a bullet to look like that after it
shattered bone.
Never.
When the bullet hit connelly,
it broke more than one bone in his body.
Broke three different bones,
I believe,
and dislodged or broke his wrist.
Like there's the bullet.
Look at it.
That's not bad.
Yeah.
When you look at it,
it,
it's,
it's bulging.
We have a picture of it here,
by the way.
There it is.
Yeah,
so it,
it is compressed,
but if you shoot a bullet in the water,
it looks like that.
Have you ever shot a bullet into water?
Uh,
no.
I haven't done.
They don't.
They don't look when the bullet is
coming out and it's,
you know,
there's
the,
the gunpowder goes off and it's flying
out.
You're going to have some distortion and
when a bullet shoots into a pillow or a
shoots into anything,
you're going to have some distortion
because of that.
Just sheer force and velocity of that
bullet.
But when you shatter bone,
when they all get bent up and distorted,
they don't get like that.
That's not something that hit anything
in my opinion.
I think that if that.
Not only that,
the way they found it on the Gurney,
on Connolly's Gurney when he was in the
hospital.
Oh look,
we found the bullet.
Here it is.
It's ridiculous.
That smacks of conspiracy,
that billet bullet more than anything.
I'm not saying that I know what
happened,
but I know that the reason why they came
up with the fact that one bullet did the
damage,
not just in Kennedy but also in
uncommonly was because they had an
account for that bullet that hit the
underpass and hit the underpass that
ricocheted hit some guy and that guy
went to the hospital.
They found the bullet hole in the
granite of the,
uh,
the,
the uh,
curb stone.
So they had to account for that.
And that's why they came up with.
It also was Arlen Specter was one of the
guys who came up with that theory.
It was a notorious scumbag.
He was on the Watergate Commissioner,
you know?
Right.
It's not a funkiness is what I'm saying
and I'm not,
but I have been in the past inclined to
gravitate towards some pretty ridiculous
conspiracies.
But that bullet is anybody that knows
anything about hunting or guns or any,
any person that I know that I've talked
to,
like what do you,
is this shot anything?
Everyone say's no,
everyone says that it hasn't hit.
But one thing to remember is that in all
investigations are fields of inquiry.
There's always an a residue of
unexplained anomalies that any theory,
physics,
theory,
evolution,
whatever,
you know,
there's always.
Yeah,
but how do you explain this one little
weird thing here that doesn't really get
accounted for by your explanation over
here.
And the answer is,
I don't know.
No theory explains everything.
But if you have an alternative theory,
you have to explain all this stuff over
here that the mainstream theory explains
and the anomalies if you want to be
taken seriously.
And usually the focus on the anomalies
is to the exclusion of all the other
stuff that is nicely explained by the
mainstream theory.
So again,
lone assassin explains a lot,
not everything.
So what do you do with the anomalies?
Nothing.
You don't have to do anything with them.
I mean that is,
it's okay to say,
okay,
that's weird.
Let's keep investigating,
but to,
to then make the leap.
But we know there was a second shooter.
No,
we just know there's anonymous.
We definitely don't know there was a
second shooter.
If there's no evidence whatsoever that
we can say,
look,
here,
we know for a fact there was a second
shooter.
We don't,
there's nothing.
Right?
But we also don't know that one bullet
did all that damage and the only reason
why we believe that one bullet did all
that damage is because that was what was
presented and that they had this one
boat.
They said that they found in Connolly's
Gurney that caused all this damage.
That seems rather unlikely.
Very,
very unlikely.
In fact,
the other thing we,
uh,
let's see,
we had the,
the number of people that heard shots,
four shots.
Whenever you say the number of people
like,
God,
man,
I just don't buy eye witness testimony
in a murder like that.
It sounds so crazy.
That's good.
Well,
that's right.
Because it's not reliable.
Well,
not only that,
there's so much chaos when you're there
and the president gets shot.
Bang,
Bang.
Right?
Everybody's adrenaline's flying.
They're running around.
I heard 100 shots.
You know,
you're going to get outliers.
You're going to get people that are
caught.
You're going to get some people that
have served in the military and are used
to like chaotic events that can recall
it clearly and soberly.
Didn't get a few of those,
but good luck sifting through all that
shit.
Right?
Eye witness evidence is.
That's one of the things that drives me
crazy.
About nine slash 11 when people are
really into the nine slash 11 story.
They say people heard explosions in the
buildings.
This guy said that he saw this and he
saw they don't know what the fuck they
saw.
These giant buildings are falling down.
Everybody's freaking out.
Yup.
I saw,
I told the story once.
I saw a squirrel in the woods once and I
thought it was a wolf for like two
seconds.
I was in Canada and I said,
well,
it's fucking squirrel.
What's wrong with me?
You know,
like I was worried about wolves,
so I thought I saw for like,
I mean I'm gonna look legit,
solid.
Two seconds I got this fucking squirrel
was a wolf,
so I don't buy the eyewitness stuff,
but I also don't buy these people that
are trying to like neatly like case
closed.
Not really.
No,
no.
There's a lot of weird shit with that
Kennedy assassination thing.
There's also a lot of people that were
mad at him because.
Absolutely.
Look,
he closed it as enemies.
He had a lot.
I mean,
Kennedy was a very volatile human being
more than Obama today.
Oh yeah.
I think so.
Actually what Kennedy was trying to do
as far as clothes,
the Federal Reserve,
he wanted to get rid of the CIA.
He wanted to do a lot.
He was opposed to secret service or
secret societies.
I mean that,
that massive speech that he did about
secret societies.
He was a very fascinating guy and a lot
of ways and you know,
flawed in many as well and I'm sure if
he was a president today who would be
involved in probably he be like one of
the most scandalous presidents of all
time,
but I'm not buying this.
I mean,
I,
I definitely don't think that Lee Harvey
Oswald was an innocent guy.
It seems pretty obvious that he was
involved in a lot of totally shit and
remember he had tried to assassinate
General Walker just in April before that
and,
and failed and we just don't think that
he was by himself.
I just don't.
I don't think it just really don't think
that he was the only one involved in
that.
It just seems the way a lone assassin
could operate that that is the likeliest
scenario.
In a free society,
you can disappear into the nooks and
crannies,
a big cities and no one will ever notice
you.
It's like the nine slash 11 up pilots
that we're training to take off but not
ever learned to land.
Why didn't we notice that?
Well,
you know,
we weren't looking for that.
Too many things going on.
It doesn't mean after the fact.
It's so easy to be an armchair
quarterback and go,
you know,
I'll tell you what they would have known
should have known well after Pearl
Harbor,
they were conspiracy theories at
Roosevelt.
Either new,
either orchestrated or knew it would
happen,
let it happen to squelch the American
firsters movement which was imported by
um,
Lindbergh and,
and,
and he had promised Churchill support,
but he can only do so much the
destroyers and all that we need to have.
And then something happens.
Okay,
so it looks like,
oh,
he must have been involved because he is
then able to act and get America into
the Second World War.
But usually politicians act in response
to something.
Now's my opportunity to take advantage
of this thing that happened to get my
way.
But all politicians do that.
It doesn't mean they're conspiring to
make the thing happen to get their way.
I don't think the argument was that he
was conspiring.
The argument was that he knew and then
pulled out some of the more major
warships.
So.
So here's the other attack it.
It's like the,
the August ninth,
2001 memo from Condoleezza Rice,
Osama bin Ladin to attack us soil.
Okay.
What about that?
Clearly Bush,
it must have known and you know,
okay,
well what we're forgetting is that the
tens of thousands of pieces of Intel
that come in every day,
this could happen as good after the
fact.
You go back and go,
oh look,
there's the one we should have known.
Same thing with Pearl Harbor.
You know Japanese might attack in
Hawaii.
Yeah,
but they might attack in the
Philippines.
They might attack Alaska,
they may attack,
you know,
and so on and so on,
which is the right one that we're
supposed to then focus our resources on.
You don't know until it happens and then
you go back and go,
you're fired because you should have
acted on that memo.
Well,
but that's why I think you would have to
be an expert in code as well.
You'd have to be an expert and to be
able to understand what they had,
what they had intercepted,
would codes it intercepted and what
information they actually had back then.
It's again,
one of those things that after the fact
it's very easy to draw conclusion saying
this had to be a conspiracy.
I mean,
I think even the history channel had
something where they were saying that
they knew that the attack was going to
happen,
they let it happen so that they could
get into world war two.
Right?
That's,
well,
that was a conspiracy theory at the time
and there was a congressional
investigation.
So the equivalent of the Warren report
about that and concluded no,
that there was no conspiracy on the part
of the US government or any
administration to,
you know,
that should be held responsible.
I mean,
a few people I think were fired for not
having the planes in the right place or
something like that.
But uh,
yeah.
But again,
that's just.
And then the other thing we had that
other psychological effect is that we
tend to,
when you're on the outside,
you tend to see big organizations is
more powerful than they really are.
Big Corporations,
CEO's,
big government agencies,
and the administrators that run them
from the outside,
it looks like.
I know they have a lot of power and they
can do a lot of things,
but when you're.
When you get the job,
then you find out,
oh,
there's a lot of things I can't do,
and here's another one of these
conspiracy theories.
That might be true.
When you get elected president,
they take you in the back room and they
go,
okay,
here's,
here's what's actually going on and get
my.
Here's what's actually going on in Iraq.
No one knows,
but you can't pull the troops.
You can't close the
base.
You can't.
Oh,
well,
I said I was going to do that yet.
Don't worry about it.
They all say that,
that you can't do it.
Oh,
all right.
You know,
I think there's a lot of act that goes
on that you don't find out that we just
don't know and we could maybe later.
It's all speculation,
but I think when you're dealing with
something like these massive global
events,
after they occur,
every people are always trying to do
some sort of investigative reporting or
trying to figure it out.
They're trying to go back over the
pieces and connect things that make
sense and the problem is you get
confirmation bias on both sides.
You get confirmation bias where people
are trying to show very clearly that
there was no conspiracy whatsoever and
then you get people to try and see
conspiracy and everything and I think
with a lot of these stories,
a lot of these major events like whether
it's jfk assassination or many other
ones,
there's a lot of weirdness to them that
make it real hard to wrap up nice and
tight and when people can't wrap them up
nice and tight,
they get very uneasy.
Yeah,
and it's.
It's okay to just say,
I don't know.
It could be a conspiracy.
Maybe not.
Let's just.
Yes,
keep an open mind.
I mean,
you don't have to conspire.
You don't have to construct a whole
nother world view of operatives and
agents plots.
You could just say that's a weird thing.
Exactly,
and I think it's also very important
that we recognize that there have been
conspiracies before like nine slash 11
by itself as a consensus 19 members of
okay,
I had a bloody and fly planes into
buildings.
That's a conveyance inspired.
Yeah.
And that's one.
That's one group that we don't know.
We also know about,
like we said,
the operation northwoods and there's
been some false flag events that
happened in the Gulf of Tonkin.
That's another one.
There's,
yeah,
there's been some lies and we know that
so it makes the whole thing like really
weird.
But this is me and these were,
we're talking about actual real events
as opposed to like psychics and Tarot
card readers or you know,
my wife's friend went to a fucking
psychic the other day and I had to
listen to this nonsense.
They were talking to me about the
psychic thing,
you know,
we went and she knew everything and she
was so amazing and she was asking me
about my aunt and how could she have
known like,
Oh,
fucking Christ first.
I wish I was there,
I wish I was there to see what kind of
questions she asked and how you
answered.
Yeah.
Because usually they tell the psychics
that fed back later while they have
these leading questions and then you
give them partial answers and then they
fish for more and then before you know
it there,
you know,
you're all,
you're filling in the blanks together
and they want to believe,
you know,
and a lot of times there's like some
weird social aspect to it,
like a hand holding or something like
that where it's like this intimacy thing
where you don't,
you don't want to be confrontational
with this person.
And so you sort of kind of helped them.
Yep.
Your bolt in each other's space because
you're only like two feet away from each
other.
It's odd.
There's a lot of oddness and a lot of
real psychodrama.
Yeah.
I had a friend who worked the psychic
friends network line back in the
nineties when Dionne Warwick on that
company.
And uh,
he's,
he was a magician that,
you know,
couldn't quite make a decent living
doing magic stuff.
So he did
this on the side and it became fairly
lucrative,
so he told me,
you know,
he operated from home and you just have
another phone line and they send you the
calls and you get,
I think he got sixty cents on the minute
and the company got,
you know,
it was three 95 a minute.
He got sixty cents on the minute,
but they rewarded you the longer you
keep them on the subjects on the line,
the more higher percentage you get of
each minute.
And uh,
so he would do this by working through
different categories and mostly people
call it night and weekends they're
lonely and need somebody to talk to,
you know,
love,
health,
money,
career,
especially love relationships,
jobs,
your boss,
you know,
people would just Yak,
Yak,
Yak.
And then he got pretty good sort of
like.
The analogy I make is like with Dr
Laura's Colin Talk Show,
you know,
sees has a rich database of problems
that people have,
why they call her and you know,
every.
So every call she knows within 10
seconds,
oh,
it's problem number seven.
It's number 16 year.
They get the one with the guy and he
just hone right in on it.
So these psychics,
they have a deep database of human
psychology connected Dr Laura to it.
Well,
she was just listen to that show.
Find similarities.
Absolutely.
No,
not that she's running a psychic scam.
Not at all,
but that,
but that the psycho,
there's only so many variations on of
human psychology and human nature.
What do people care the most about
relationships,
you know,
love health.
Many career.
So you just work your way through those
four.
And then people just open up and pour
stuff out,
take a few notes and then like 45
minutes later.
Well,
let's talk about your,
you know,
your uncle Bob.
Bob,
how could he have known about uncle?
Well,
you told them half an hour ago so people
forget that.
So if you record them,
you video tape and more tape recorder.
It's very enlightening.
Um,
uh,
I did a show with John Stossel when he
was with ABC 20 slash 20 on,
on,
uh,
John and James and Prague and they got
a,
they didn't tell Vanpraagh guy was
involved,
but they taped them all day,
uh,
bringing people in to do readings and
cameras and set up and stuff like this.
And when you sit there with a counter,
like how many times has he asked this
question or say these things and it's
just hundreds.
And so his hit rate was maybe less than
10 percent,
but they only remembered that,
that,
you know,
the handful of the 10 percent and forgot
the hundreds of names he would throw out
and comments he would make.
And so there's a confirmation bias.
There's a,
you know,
a high data,
high data rate,
you just pouring stuff out and then
people pick out the ones that they
remember and then we'd catch him
cheating once in a while like,
you know,
well,
let's take a break.
Everybody break.
Then you leave the camera rolling and
then he starts chatting with people you
know.
So who are you here for?
Oh my aunt,
she passed over.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then like half an hour later I'd
like to come to this woman here.
Now don't tell me who you're here for,
but I'm getting.
I see a woman on your,
over your left shoulder.
I don't want to say sister mother.
Is it an aunt?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And it looks,
you know,
it's uh,
it's edited and the way it looks,
you know,
like they,
they're really getting something.
But when you,
when you really see it in operation,
you can see the whole thing unfolds
completely as a psychodrama.
Well,
we had this guy on the show,
his name is,
he's abandoned.
I know he's great and it's fantastic
because he's a magician and he does
those psychic reading things,
but he'll tell you right away,
this is a trick.
I am really good at it.
I am not a psychic.
I have no psychic ability whatsoever,
but I can't tell you how I'm doing this,
but I know how to do this.
Right.
And he was bending spoons and doing all
this craziness and you know,
did card tricks,
all kinds of crazy stuff where you go,
this is insane,
how is this possible?
But he was really adamant about letting
you know,
like these people that are psychics that
are telling you about your future,
your past,
they're all con people.
They're all,
they're doing terrible things.
They're trying to pretend that you're
dead relatives are communicating with
you from the great beyond.
They're giving you this sense of hope,
but they're all scammers.
And you know,
having a guy like that who's very
skilled at that style of what we.
I think he calls it,
he's a mentalist.
A mentalist.
Yeah.
It's,
it's amazing to watch though.
It is.
God is so good at it.
Bannon checks one of the best.
Yeah.
But he's also one of the,
sort of one of the leaders of a
skeptical movement.
Yes.
Which is ethical magic.
He's an entertainer and it's not doing
anything horrible.
You know,
he's not ripping anybody off and he's
really adamant about it.
So I,
I love him.
Yeah.
I love what he was on a cruise with him
on set one of these cruise ship things
with other skeptics and uh,
so he did some of these mentalism stuff
and he,
he told me how he did one of them and
he's,
he's pretty good about not telling the
truth,
but I really pressed him on this
particular thing when he would touch
somebody like on the shoulder here and
then you're blindfolded and then,
and then you would say,
I felt like you touched me on the same,
you know,
the left shoulder,
that right.
And you had a whole sequence of these
things where the other person was
picking up on the queue of where he was
being touched.
So anyway,
I was just stunned by this,
like,
how is he doing this?
I know he's not really psychic,
you know?
And then he told me how he did it.
I'm like,
Oh,
oh,
that is so good and it's so simple,
but you can't tell us.
Uh,
but,
and,
and that's really probably the best
reason why you don't want to know how
the magicians do it because it's almost
always super simple.
And like,
Oh,
I should've seen that penn and teller
was penn.
Jillette teller really doesn't talk that
much,
but there was an old show that was on
television in Australia or radio,
I think it was on radio or television,
I don't remember.
But there was this trick that they did.
Um,
and it was the way the pen like,
god damn it,
I'm trying to,
I'm struggling to remember how exactly
it worked,
but it was this woman who could,
uh,
she,
she could tell the future or she could,
she could some sort of psychic ability.
And penn explained it and the way he
explained it,
he didn't want to explain
it like they did it on the rate is for
radiolab,
radiolab podcast.
And they explained it on there.
I'm doing a terrible Job explaining
this,
but when you hear the explanation,
I won't give it out because I don't want
to ruin it for anybody who hasn't heard
it before.
But when you hear the explanation,
you go,
oh god,
yeah,
that's it.
Of course fuckers fuckers.
But,
but having that,
the ability to sneaky trick people like
that.
But you can make a lot of money if
you're an unethical person and you can
fool a lot of people and you know,
but like one of the examples I use,
you know penn and teller do the cups and
balls,
but they use clear plastic cups so you
can see where the ball is and how it's
being done.
But you still,
you still get fooled.
Yes.
Because the power of the,
you know,
the sort of following his gaze or
following the movement of the hand and
this and that.
It's done so well that you still miss it
with a clear plastic with it.
So this is a good example where even
knowing the trick,
you might still be fooled.
What is it about people that want to
fund the.
Is it,
is it something about the search for
human knowledge?
Like the thing that's always inside of
people where they're trying to find out
where's the food,
where's the enemy coming from?
What's going to happen in the future as
it seems to be like some search for
human knowledge that is a part of
people's desire to uncover mystery.
You know,
there's almost like a genetic calling
find.
well,
what it is is just,
it's just learning and survival.
So I call this patternicity the tendency
to find meaningful patterns in both
meaningful and meaningless noise.
And my thought experiment is imagine
you're a hominid on the plains of africa
three and a half million years ago,
small brain australopithecine,
your name is lucy,
and that you hear a rustle in the grass.
Is that a dangerous predator or is it
just the wind?
So if you assume that the rustle in the
grass is a dangerous predator and it
turns out it's just the wind,
that's a type one error,
a false positive,
you thought a was connected to be but
but no harm you,
you just become skiddish and cautious or
whatever.
But if you assume that the rustle in the
grass is just the wind and it turns out
it's a dangerous predator,
your lunch just been given a darwin
award for taking yourself out of the
gene pool early before reproducing.
So in other words,
it's better to just assume that all
things you think Are connected,
all rustles in the grass are dangerous
predators and not the wind,
just in case,
and there's not.
There's not a big cost to pay for making
a type one error,
a false positive.
There is a higher cost for making a type
two error or false negative.
So we assume that this is the basis of
superstition and magical thinking.
We just assume that this is connected to
that you pull the slot and you do this,
you pull the slot machIne,
you win or whatever,
and this is what skinner show back in
the fifties where you just randomly give
reinforcements to rats and pigeons and
whatever they were doing just before
they got rewarded.
They'll just repeat that behavior.
Even if it's like twirling
counterclockwise twice and that's the
basis of superstition it.
There's nothing wrong with their brains.
They're just trying to find causal
connections between events,
the environment,
and that's the basis of survival.
So all of us are subject to making those
connections.
Some are more gullible than others.
Say are more skeptical,
but for the most part all of us can
easIly be fooled if it's done right.
That's.
that's the beauty of good cons,
good scams is that anybody could fall
for them,
even smart people,
and if anything,
smart people are more likely to believe
weird things in this sense that once
they believe it,
they think they've drawn a connection.
They're Better at rationalizing the
reasons why they believe than say,
less educated or less intelligent
people.
And so as people like panacek will tell
you,
there's nothing better than an audience
of scientists at mit.
Oh boy,
I can really fool them because they
think they're so smart.
I can't be full to wow,
okay.
He must be doing something really,
really super psychic because you know,
I'm super smart,
but.
Well no,
because all of our sensory apparatus
works the same and magicians know how to
manipulate your gaze,
your attention,
whatever,
and had a fool you.
this is so weird how people are drawn to
trying to uncover mystery so you know,
whether it's ghosts or whether it's a
like how many goddamn go shows do they
have to have where no one ever sees it
knows they stop having go shows.
I know those things drive me crazy.
We don't do very many issUes like on
astrology.
Is it real?
It's like we took care of this,
you know,
decades ago.
There's nothing new.
Okay.
Astrology as far as like,
you know,
hey,
you're a leo,
so you're inclined to be a leader.
Like that kind of bullshit.
But is there anything to those really
complex astrological readings?
Were they,
they look for the time of day you were
born and mercury's and retro.
Yeah.
Have you looked into that?
I know nothing about it.
Nothing to it.
Nothing at all.
Nope.
Absolutely nothing.
It's all in the psychology of the
reading.
So if you mix up somebody's reading for,
you know,
you're a leo,
but you know,
we gave you the virgo reading or
whatever for that day.
Almost everybody go,
yeah,
boy,
that's all total hustle.
Yeah,
all of that.
What about nancy reagan?
She believed,
I don't understand what you're saying.
Yes.
God rest her soul.
God rest her soul didn't use a psychic.
She consulted a little bit.
I mean,
they got played up quite a bit,
uh,
for ronnie's travel schedule a little
bit.
Uh,
I don't think we can say that state
decisions were made based on
astrological readings
and it could've also been like,
you know,
you always know someone who has a wacky
husband or a wacky wife,
that believability shit.
And then the person sort of like,
oh dear,
what did you say?
Okay,
I'll listen.
You know,
how I don't think president reaGan was
paying much attention to it.
He wasn't paying much attention to
anything towards the end,
you know,
but,
uh,
but this desire to uncover hidden
mysteries is always been really
confusing to me because,
uh,
myself personally,
I've felt the pole like,
especIally like aliens and ufo,
like I went
deep,
deep into like,
uh,
when I was real young.
Um,
I um,
cut into the roswell thing and uh,
there's a lot of different connections
with the roswell conspiracy about this
crashed ufo in New Mexico in 1947 and
all the eye witness reports and boy,
you go down the rabbit hole of that
thing and you could waste years of your
life.
You know,
there was a study done In a,
it was a ufo report.
Then in the late fifties,
I think it was 59 on the 500 most
important ufo cases of the last 20
years.
Roswell wasn't even on the list,
but how is it not on the list?
Roswell didn't become roswell until 1980
when there was a made for tv movie.
And then charles berlitz that language,
a book publisher,
he got into,
they got me those fucks,
those books going after van donican,
chariots of the gods,
that bestseller.
Then book started pouring out about
aliens and ufo.
And then there was the movie,
remember when the chariots of the gods
of the film was released in the
theaters.
I remember leonard nimoy and search.
Oh yeah,
man,
a conjecture and was,
was a great job.
I loved that,
I used to watch that show,
but that's,
that got me in a big foot.
But that's an example of,
of um,
you know,
how the popular media drives a lot of
these things.
What do we really know back then?
Nothing.
I mean,
it was just a couple of little anomalous
things.
And here's an example,
you know,
conspiracy.
Okay.
So the government lied when they said it
was a weather balloon.
Yes.
They did your surprise that governments
lie really?
Because of course it was an national,
it was a,
it was a high altitude surveillance
balloon listening for the acoustic
signatures of a nuclear explosion in the
upper atmosphere,
but it's soviet.
So of course when this debris came down
and you know,
the farmer's field there outside of
albuquerque have a roswell,
New Mexico,
of course they're not going to come out
and hold a press conference.
You go,
well,
let's see.
Actually what we are doing is launching
this project to listen to soviet.
It was suspicious too when something
becomes not just a story,
but it also becomes business.
And roswell became a giant business so
much,
much later.
Uh,
you know,
again,
there were a bunch of sightings in the
forties and fifties and,
but,
but that's around the time that there
was a lot of experimental aircraft,
horse and so whenever,
but anybody says,
well,
I saw this triangular shaped black
thing.
Are you near an air force base?
Have you looked at pictures of the b two
bomber,
the stealth bomber?
It's sort of a delta shaped wing shaped.
And when it flies right over the rose
parade every January 1st comes right
over my house and altadena circles right
when it comes at you,
it's silent and it's this weird black
because they painted that black paint
that doesn't reflect and if you didn't
know about it and you're out in the
desert and it's dusk and yeah,
it's like a big kind of spooky.
Like what I saw one when I was a film
and fear factor in 2002.
So it was right after september 11,
not far,
not long afterwards.
And we were filming out there
in a way out in the desert area.
Palm dale,
I guess it wasn't.
Yeah.
And it's real close to the air force
base and we saw a stealth bomber flying
over and it looks like an alien space.
Yeah,
it's amazing when you see one,
you're like,
whoa.
Like if you didn't know and you had
never heard one of those before and you
looked up in the sky,
you'd be sure that that came from
another planet.
I mean,
it looks like it's right out of star
wars in the eighties and nineties there
were ufo sightings in America.
And the ufo is looked strangely like
blimps.
That's weird.
Yeah.
So that,
that's the kind of thing people see
weird things.
And again,
the propensity is not to just say,
I saw an anomaly.
Wow.
I don't know.
That's weird.
And leave it at that.
Our mind immediately goes back to your
idea.
We love the mystery.
Let's concoct this whole thing.
The martians are coming and it's the
aliens and there's a whole nother
worldview.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
it's like this,
um,
there's this anomalous star kic with a
bunch of numbers that dims about 20
percent every period of time,
whatever that is.
It's about 1400 light years away.
So,
uh,
and the astronomers study in this
decide,
okay,
it's not planets,
it's not comments coming around in front
of us that dims the light.
Um,
so,
so immediately people go to.
It's a dyson sphere.
It's a gigantic solar collecting array
that circles around the planet that
collects energy from the sun.
Oh,
this is a recent story.
Reasons.
So,
but you know what?
I did some radio shows,
uh,
locally about this.
And immediately the host go to will.
Well,
whAt do they like?
What,
what does,
who like the aliens?
Like,
no,
no.
All of this we have is just an anomaly
in the light,
you know,
signature of this start.
That's all we have.
We don't have.
The Problem also with social media is it
becomes click bait.
It becomes someone writes a blog or
someone has a thing and there's a video
that's linked to it and then everybody
starts sending that out to their
friends.
And before you know it,
that becomes the narrative,
right?
Yep,
that's right.
Found some sort of a gigantic satellite
that's orbiting.
Whether it's like a death star that's
reading this planet,
it dims it because it comes into,
you know,
between us and that,
yeah,
that kind of stuff is very confusing to
a lot of people because you don't have
enough time to really research it right
now.
That's why something like what you do,
like skeptic magazine or the entire
skeptic community is a great resource
and snopes,
snopes.com.
Snopes is fantastic where it breaks down
and goes,
okay,
here's what we absolutely know for a
fact.
So look at that.
It's okay to just say,
I don't know.
Yeah,
but I just always hard to remember that.
I've always been so confused as to what
it is about what I mean.
I've known grown adults that have spent
years and years with real life,
like fascinated with big foot,
you know,
fascinated with ufo is fascinated with
these mysteries and you,
when you look at the amount of resources
that they,
they actually expand chasing after these
things and say,
well if you that into like something
positive,
something constructed a,
my god,
you know,
you,
you would,
you would do so well.
Like I often see that thing about like
certain scammers and I'm like,
my god,
if these people just started a business
with the same amount of enthusiasm,
right,
how good would they be doing?
Right?
I mean,
those guys running the,
the,
uh,
internet scams and stuff,
what if they just did a legitimate
company,
they'd probably make more money.
What is it about mysteries?
That's one of the real important things
that I wanted to talk to you about.
I think one of the appeals of the ufo
aliens thing is it's kind of a secular
religion because they're often portrayed
as god like figures and if you don't
believe in the traditional god,
then that is kind of,
they're out there.
They're very powerful.
They know about us.
They're coming to rescue us,
save us.
So much of science fiction is,
you know,
has these kinds of themes to it.
Uh,
like the day the earth stood still,
that classic 1951 film,
michael,
randy as klaatu and the ship comes to
Washington dc.
It's a christ allegory that he's come to
talk to the authorities,
you know,
humans are sending.
We have to stop this,
this case,
it was nuclear war and the remake with
keanu reeves.
It was global warming and the
authorities want to see him.
So he mingles among the common people
like jesus did.
And then he takes up with the Patricia
Neal character who's the single mom in
the town and uh,
and,
and then he's killed by the authorities
and he's putting the more you put in
this morgue,
which is sort of like the tomb.
And then in that famous scene where
Patricia Neal goes to the robot,
he's standing there and the pfizer comes
up and he's going to zapper and she
gives him the famous message,
you know,
gore cloud to burrata,
nick,
which basically says,
go get clapped.
At least he's in the,
he's in the tomb.
So he,
he marches over to the tomb and burns a
hole in it,
takes the body,
returns it to the ship and resurrection
right there.
Jesus.
It's like,
it's his name in the,
in the movie was Mr.
Carpenter,
earthly name mr carmen are interested
in.
And in the original script,
um,
uh,
we're in the film.
She says,
wow,
that's incredible.
You mean this is the power of science
and technology in the future,
and the original script,
he says,
yeah,
this is where it's gone,
but the brain censorship board,
1951 said you can't say that,
that you know,
americans will be offended by this.
So they changed the line and now he says
something like,
no,
no one has the power over life and
death.
Only the great spirit can determine,
you know,
was just some bologna line and,
but,
but so much of,
of the way we talk about aliens is that
they are,
like,
I call them deities are atheists,
they're like gods and the chariots of
the gods.
I mean that's kind of that thesis,
but it's not so far fetched in the sense
that if not that they've come here,
they probably haven't come here,
but if they're out there and they
probably are,
there's good reasons to think there's
extraterrestrials and if we encountered
them,
they're not going to be behind us
technologically because we wouldn't
encounter them otherwise.
So if we do find a signal or whatever
it's going to be from an advance how far
advanced,
so the chances of them being in parallel
with us on an evolutionary timescale,
virtually zero,
you know they're going to be,
and if they're out of sync by just a
little bit from when they started on
their planet evolving,
it would be millions of years in
advance.
And look what we've been able to
accomplish just in say a hundred years
of of technology,
50 years of computer technical.
Why would it have to be millions of
years in advanced?
Couldn't it just be 100 or 100 years in
advance of us?
If we're thinking about colonizing mars
the next few decades,
right?
You get some sort of an advanced
civilization that has less conflict in
us because of how long it takes to get
from bacterial grade life to an
intelligent communicating like probably
three and a half billion years is how
long it took here.
So wherever,
whenever your plant it starts,
the chances of it going to be in perfect
synchrony of every step along the way
from bacterial grade life to big brains.
If anything,
it's probably going to be millions of
years of difference in timescale,
just just on the biology.
So just randomly meet even to get to
where we are.
It could be a million plus or minus just
to reach this level correct where we've
reached just whatever billion years it
was.
Didn't have to be.
That number.
Could have been much longer,
could have been shorter or just started
later.
We started earlier.
We'll also,
we have to deal with the impact that
killed the dinosaurs.
That could be all the random events that
happened.
It could be,
they could be on a planet that doesn't
have any random events like that or it'd
be way ahead of,
or they could be on one that has a lot
of them.
So the answer to the fermi paradox that
whereas everybody,
because they should have happened
already,
is probably,
uh,
the universe timi with bacterial grade
life.
But the number of steps to get from
there all the way to communicating
technological society is enormous.
And so that winnows down the number of
possibilities you can get all the way
to,
to neanderthals like here on earth,
you know,
they're big brain,
1500 ccs,
but the size of our brain maybe a little
bit larger.
And uh,
you know,
they had fire,
they had tools.
I'm at tesco,
everything but disco,
uh,
and they had europe to themselves are
about 300,000
years and there's no advancement in
their toolkits.
They're all pretty much the same.
They never had cave paintings.
They didn't look like they had symbolic
art like a homo sapiens did.
I believe their brains were larger
though to deal with their larger bodies.
Well,
even when you correct for body size,
theiR brains are slightly larger,
but only slightly.
It may be the brain size may not make
any difference.
Maybe brain modularity,
maybe they didn't have language,
or if they did,
maybe they didn't have communicate
symbolic language.
We don't know why they went extinct.
but when humans,
homo sapiens arrived in europe,
within a few tens of thousands of years,
there was no more a neanderthals gun.
They went extinct and there's a big
debate paleoanthropology circles.
Why so?
But,
but my point is thAt you could have a
three and a half billion years of
evolution on a planet and get all the
way to neanderthals who have stone tools
and it just stops.
For whatever reason,
they never developed symbolic
communication.
They have opposable thumbs so they can
make stuff,
they can make tools,
but they never make the next step.
Right now,
some people disagree with that.
They,
they,
they think that had a homo sapiens,
not dominated europe when they came in.
Neanderthals might have gotten there
within a few centuries more maybe,
but we,
you know,
we don't know that well.
There's also the thought that even
though the unIverse is infinite,
right,
that it had some sort of a beginning,
whether you buy or don't buy,
that there's actually been some
arguments.
Wasn't there some arguments recently
that the,
perhaps the universe didn't have a
beginning or an end,
but that it's been an eternal.
That's always been,
it could be eternally cycling there,
there could be multiple big bang.
So there was never.
Yeah.
So the idea could possibly be that if
that is the case.
Right?
So if you have an event and from that
event things become more and more
complex.
Start getting single cell life,
multicellular life like we have here on
earth.
There has to be a first like us first.
It has to.
Somebody has to be first.
Maybe first.
Yes,
that's what I'm saying.
Like if I exist multigenerational our
stars.
And so there's been many,
many generations of stars older than
ours.
So this is the pheromone.
Where is everybody.
I mean there should have been somebody
made it for.
But when you think about how complex
life is on earth and how many different
varieties of it,
and there's only one human,
there's only one technologically
communicating species and where it so,
so is it possible?
Yeah,
that's right.
You got to have a planet teaming with
life with dolphins and chimpanzees,
big brains.
And they lots of puppies and they never,
they never built it,
you know,
they no laptops,
nothing.
Yeah.
So it is possible that we,
since we exist,
it is possible the,
we're the only ones that exist.
Uh,
it's possible.
It's totally possible.
We just don't know.
but that's terrifying.
The seti argument that search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
scientists,
these aren't the ufo people.
There are their counter argument to that
is there,
but there are so many planets now that
we know about,
virtually every star in the galaxy of
100 billion stars has planet.
So we're talking hundreds and hundreds
of billions of planets.
The chances that it never happened
anywhere,
you know?
Okay.
It's a small,
it's pretty small.
So they probably out there somewhere,
but it's a vast empty,
you know,
cosmos,
you know that there's a lot that we know
that doesn't have intelligent life,
that a lot of plants,
right?
We have one planet that we know of,
that as intelligent life at all the
plants we've ever discovered.
And obviously there's some that we've
discovered that are so far out there,
we only get glimpses of what their
atmosphere contains.
Well,
the next generation,
they'll,
they'll be able to get the atmospheres,
the,
uh,
the webb space telescope will,
I'm told they just getting it from a
light spectrum.
now in the,
in the spectrum,
you could see if there's oxygen,
for example,
in methane,
so they must have cows that are
forwarding methane.
Methane,
the british say to sound intelligent,
I try to use british.
You spelled tires with a y t,
y r e s c u under the hitchens and
dawkins,
he's got that british accent.
It sounds so much better.
Super things and late night tv.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yup.
It works.
So yeah.
Anyway,
the mystery.
You talked about us about the mystery.
Well,
you know,
there's not quite sure why our brains go
toward that.
I mean,
I'm sure my dog has a good life,
but I don't think he contemplates the
cosmos.
Does dogs a loser,
especially when it's time for food.
When I was trying to get at though is
that there's,
there's a thing that we do where it's
not just.
I mean,
there's,
there's the longing for extra
terrestrial life,
you know,
the search for the technological daddy,
the,
uh,
advanced alien daddy that's out there
that's going to show us the error of our
ways.
There's,
there's that pole.
but then there's also this weird poll
where we want to believe that these
intelligent beings from another planet
can recognize who our elected leaders
are and be In cahoots with them as if
they give a shit about obama or
anything.
I mean,
if you like descended upon an ant
colony,
would you have a deal with the queen?
Like,
look,
I know you're the one who in charge of
this.
So I'll talk to you this election.
You don't want to be super secretive and
since you are so moral and ethical,
you know,
and you don't lie to your people at all.
I'm only gonna communicate with you.
And in exchange for technological
secrets,
I would like some dna like is so
preposterous,
stupid idea that they would come down
and they would talk to the military
leaders,
especially military leaders from the
1940 [inaudible] who knew almost nothing
about technology or this idea that they,
you know,
at roswell know we capture when their
spacecraft and back engineered their
technology and that's where it's silicon
chips and computers came from.
Do you know about the american computer
company?
Did you ever hear about these people?
There was a company called the american
computer company and this was back
during the,
um,
art bell days of a coast to coast with
heartfelt wish.
I loved coming home many that I've been
on it once to,
was the one of the highlights of my
life.
I was recently when he came back on the
radio or internet.
So I was driving home from the comedy
store one night and they had this,
uh,
they were talking about this american
computer company and this guy that rents
american computer company,
that was,
he's out of his fucking mind.
And he apparently he had this theory and
this whole website dedicated,
I don't know if it's up anymore,
they might have taken it down with,
is dedicated to showing the timeline of
the creation of the transistor and all
this came out of bell labs,
which is where they had the air force
base outside of bell labs to protect it
from alien invasion.
Oh my god.
And that this is where all of our
technology came from.
The we're supposed to Believe that the
aliens were
only about five to 10 years more
advanced than us from vacuum tubes to
the silicon transistors.
I mean,
really that's it.
That's the fiber optics.
They managed to traverse the best
instance of interstellar space with
technology.
Just barely better than vacuum tubes
with agera.
Pay attention to that.
Robert lasar guy.
he's.
Yes.
Bizarre ones.
He's a bizarre.
It sounds so good.
I think there are some people that just
make stuff up.
He's so good at it though,
but he's also smart,
which is fucking really scary because
this guy came up with a hydrogen powered
engine for his corvette.
You know,
which people have done,
you know,
they're doing it now,
like people are developing hydrogen
power plants for cars,
but he had this like decades ago.
So he's obviously a very smart and
smart,
doesn't,
uh,
doesn't protect you from believing and
weird things.
Isn't that bizarre?
They are not just believing in weird
things,
but bullshitting ps,
right?
Yeah.
Well then somebody who's smart,
educated is going to be better at,
at bullshitting people.
Well,
he was.
He bullshitted people about is education
too though.
That was part of the problem.
I think some people went back and looked
through his education,
said,
well,
there's no evidence that you ever went
to the school.
And so that,
that through some monkey wrenches into.
He was one of the area.
Fifty one guys were saying worked at
area 51.
Yep.
Well,
area 51 is a top secret.
A military base or they.
So you know,
you and I aren't gonna be able to drive
there.
Go wherever we're doing a show.
We want to blow the lid off these crazy.
You know,
you're still not coming in here.
Oh,
okay.
So what are you hiding?
Well,
you know,
of course there,
it'd be interesting to know now that we
know about the b two stealth bomber,
what are they doing now that we won't
find out for 20 more years that people
are seeing out in the desert in the
middle of the night?
I saw this spooky.
Weird.
Definitely.
And that's how it works.
We find out eventually in the meantime,
just say,
I don't know,
it's a weird thing.
Well,
the uh,
the,
the oddest part about it is this belief
that they're in,
in conspiracy with our elected leaders,
that,
that one to me has been so strange that
they will land somewhere and they have
these meetings and these elected leaders
make deals with the ufo.
How amazing would that be though,
if that was true courage?
They're reptilians are running the
country from New Mexico.
people love this idea of blowing the lid
off of it.
You know,
that's something that people love.
They love investigating.
They love the investigative journalism
aspect of blowing the lid off this
global conspiracy.
Well,
I think that's what drives some of the
kind of anti medical establishment,
anti big pharma anti-vaccination,
you know,
those guys,
they're behind closed or the big
powerful people,
cOrporations and government agents,
the cdc and this company and the ceo and
the politic,
you know,
they're all and they want to make money
and you know,
and,
and they,
they first,
they think they're more powerful than
they really are.
And second,
that's not how the world works.
I mean,
these people are not tryinG to keep us
poisoned or keep us sick so they can
make money.
You
know,
it's the real conspiracies are,
you know,
how can we can't get our drugs cheaper?
Uh,
you know,
those are the,
what sort of behind the door deals are
being done.
Uh,
you know,
that prevent healthcare from being
cheaper.
That's where the real,
the real conspiracy.
I had a conversation with someone who's
trying to tell me they already have a
cure for cancer or they just don't want
you to have the cure because then
they'll know the money's in the
treatment.
I gO,
why do you think the same person has the
cure as the the same people that are
selling the treatment really think
they're the same person.
Right?
Do you have any people work in the field
of creating new medicine?
I mean,
that's so ridiculous that it would be
the one person of the tens of thousands
of employees at amgen or wherever is
going to,
you know,
leave and go,
oh,
I found something out and I'm coming on
your show to tell you I took pictures.
Here's was not one.
Well,
it just doesn't make any sense that it
would be the same person.
The odds of it being the same person or
the same company,
the,
there's so many different people that
work in the pharmaceutical industry.
So many different people that are trying
to do research on new medications and
there's so much money involved in it
that there's one company would come up
with a cure and they would like to keep
it under wraps because they are in
cahoots with the other company that's
got the treatment.
Right.
And so,
I mean,
if this were true then then all the
people that were sick from polio and all
the Businesses and companies that were
making money from polio patients,
how come they didn't stop the polio
vaccine?
Right?
Or you know,
just pick any,
any,
you know,
any particular industry like that where
we have made real progress.
but then there are some things where you
go,
okay,
there's definitely too many people that
are getting prescribed pain pills.
Like what?
What is going on?
And what is the conspiracy that I've,
I've had conversations with people that
went to doctors now they have something
wrong with them and the doctor wants to
prescribe them.
I had a fucking nose operation.
I had a deviated septum repaired and my
doctor gave me not one,
but two different opiates to take.
I didn't take anything.
My,
I wasn't in pain.
Okay.
And he was like,
you're going to be in pain.
I'm like,
I'm telling you man,
I barely.
It's barely uncomfortable.
Well,
so again,
we know how some of this works.
You know,
the,
the drug companies take the doctors out
on their golfing trips.
They give them free samples and this and
that.
Well,
my wife's mom was a nurse and they used
to take them out to dinner.
These pharmaceutical reps would talk to
them and they want.
It wasn't like they said,
hey,
we want you to tell these people to take
our drugs.
It's,
they became friendly and they did nice
things to them and it was almost
understood that in exchange you would
talk well about their drug or the
principle of reciprocity for you.
Now you owe me.
You don't even have to say it.
They wanted those trips.
They want.
You don't have to say it.
That's where it's interesting.
You don't have to say it right.
And so they're making money and that's,
that's reality.
I mean the,
the,
the sheer volume of pain pills that
they've sold in this country since the
19 eighties.
It's stunning.
But also I saw this when my,
um,
my step dad was ill for,
oh,
probably 10 years of just going through
in his eighties,
just melting down one thing after
another.
And I was the one taking them around all
the different docs and you know,
I could sort of see how it works.
He's like,
you know,
the dogs go look a dick.
I don't know.
I don't know what the problem is.
Well,
can you give me something?
I'm in pain right?
Well doc,
come on,
I just drove down here.
All right here,
take this.
You know.
So they kind of feel like,
well I got to do something.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what to do,
but okay,
he's asking me,
all right,
I'll give him some painkillers.
I'll give him this or that makes it feel
better.
And my dad would take it like,
yeah,
this is great.
There's certainly that.
There's also certainly incompetent
doctors.
There's doctors that are really willing
to prescribe ssri antidepressants like
with alarming,
right?
Consistency.
So there you have the medicalization of
what are really probably just social
behavioral issues.
So you know,
when we were kids in school and a little
johnny was super active and had high
energy,
whatever.
Okay.
And now he's a great athlete or he's
doing this or that.
And now he's like,
well,
what's wrong with him?
Oh,
well he has this medical pro.
he's a d,
h,
d.
Oh,
oh,
that's a thing.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a medical issue.
It's like a disease.
Well,
what can we give them for it?
we'll give them,
you know,
these drugs here and okay,
so all of a sudden,
you know,
the hyperactive little kid who's just
kind of fun and maybe a little
disruptive is now medicalized.
And it's the same thing with the,
you know,
the autism spectrum,
people say,
well,
you know,
increase in vaccinations.
There's been an increase in autism,
not really.
The category got larger and it became
medicalized,
you know,
so.
So there's no increase in autism cases.
It's the increase in the diagnoses of
them at a more people paying attention
to it and be the categories much bigger
than it used to be.
So that's why it's called a spectrum.
So when people make the correlation
between that and the increase in the
amount of vaccinations to children,
it's a false correlation.
Yeah.
It says it's not true that the,
that autism rates have gone up.
It's that in the,
in the nineties it's suddenly started
becoming a thing,
autism,
the spectrum,
talking about it.
And so somebody that was like so called
asperger's,
they're a little socially awkward.
Is that a word burglary?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm pretty sure I've heard the dude's a
little ass burglary when someone's like
really smart,
but socially to go to caltech or mit,
you know,
the big bang theory is not so far off on
the nerdy fact.
Yes.
But,
but again,
it goes along with being false
correlation.
What's wrong with being a little nerdy?
Well,
now it's,
you're on the autism spectrum.
Yeah.
You're on the spectrum that we,
the autistic,
yet you're,
and you have a disease and we have drugs
for this.
And before you know it,
the categories bigger than there's more
people in the box.
So it looks like it got bigger,
but it didn't.
If you're easily distracted also add.
Yeah.
Uh,
you have a disease,
you have add,
sir,
you need to take,
they call it a dos to attention deficit.
Uh,
oh,
shiny,
right.
Does that.
So,
but there have been.
There's
also the very real problem with human
beings in that there's so much
biological diversity that medication
that affects one person is going to
affect another person that totally
different way.
So if they give you a medication or your
body has no problem with that medication
whatsoever,
they give that same medication to
another person.
There's going to be some issues.
And when people say,
well,
you know,
my child got vaccinated and some,
there was some adverse reaction to the
vaccination.
There's,
there's people that want to immediately
dismiss that and say,
well,
that's malarkey.
That's junk science.
But there is a very real situation that
happens with human beings where they
take medication where it does not agree
with some of them.
Sort of how,
like some people have allergies to
things that are completely innocuous to
were I,
you give,
uh,
a certain type of nut to jamie and he
might die.
You know,
there's,
there's a reality to that.
And when you look at the,
this is what I've tried to explain to
people that you talking about
vaccinations being dangerous and you
know,
we don't need vaccinations than other
horrible the people.
And all the,
all the people that have like think
about how many people you're talking
about,
you're talking about 300 million in this
country alone.
How many cases have,
are people that have vaccInations where
things go wrong?
Is it a thousand a year?
Well,
if it is a thousand a year,
do you know how low that is?
I know that's not low.
If it's your child,
it's awful.
I know it's not love.
It's 10 a year.
If it's your child,
it's awful.
But there's a lot of fucking People that
are being vaccinated.
If there really was this global epidemic
of you give kids vaccinations and they
turn into,
you know,
the decrepitude,
mentally disabled child boy,
it'll be a lot bigger.
Be a lot bigger than it is because so
many people were getting vaccinated
exactly the right way to think about a
million to one odds happened 300 times a
day in America.
Yeah,
I can't think of it.
And that's a lot of people.
It's a lot of people just want to try to
explain to people.
When we talk about just the raw numbers
of stupidity,
I think that it's really conservative
and really kind to say that one out of
100 people are fucking idiots and
there's not a damn thing to do.
That's really,
that's openminded.
That's really looking at the bright side
of things.
That's a glass half full perspective,
right?
That means there's 3 million morons in
this country and we know where they are.
That's a lot of people,
lot of people.
It's the sheer numbers that we deal
with.
Whenever you know,
when,
when people started throwing these,
you know,
these theories around and they use this
as their evidence.
I always try to just try to put it into
that perspective.
You just stop and think about the
numbers.
If you could see it on a board,
if you could see 7 billion human beings
just as little dots on a board and then
you know,
then let's,
let's find them.
All right,
then let's,
let's look at the problems.
Let's look at the.
Oh,
this is what we're dealing with.
We're dealing with is almost
insurmountable numbers be like a cancer
cluster who accepted to be a stupidity
cluster because they're going to cluster
in various places,
easily cities probably,
and they'll find each other and then
there's.
There's the confirmation bias that comes
from the groups getting together and
only sharing information that correlates
to their beliefs,
whether it's big photo ufo lfos or
psychics or.
That's why it seems like you know,
any of these groups that have people are
the big foot people or whatever it seems
like.
Well,
there's a lot of people.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
there's maybe $100 a night club or
something like that,
but it's a small number of people
compared to the whole population.
will they get so mad?
They get so mad when you bring this up.
If you bring up these facts or this,
these thoughts,
these ideas,
and you tell these people that you don't
believe in ufos or you don't believe
that we've ever been visited thinking
emotionally men,
they are connected.
They're connected.
Yet they're,
they're,
they're connected.
Like who they are is connected to these
Beliefs and the more psychologically
invested you are in unbelief,
the harder it is to change your mind.
so this was,
this is again an example of cognitive
dissonance which was discovered by leon
festinger and uh,
december of 1954 on the 21st,
he went to the top of a hill with a ufo
cult who was waiting for the mothership
to come.
And he wanted to see,
well,
presumably the mothership is not going
to come.
The world won't come to an end.
What will they do afterwards?
So he thought,
well,
I mean,
they just changed their mind when they
go home,
whatever.
So he recorded this and wrote a book
about it called when prophecY fails.
And the answer is they doubled down on
their belief that they say,
well,
this was a dumb idea.
Let's go home.
You know,
they went home and started recruiting
more people and while we miscalculated
a,
it was eastern standard time.
It was tomorrow night or it's next year.
We've got to carry the one when we did
our end of the world calculations.
And so,
and so they recruit more people to join
the group,
so he called this cognitive dissonance
that,
you know,
when you have a Belief that conflicts
with the facts,
uh,
what gives well,
the facts have to give because the
belief is right.
So we're going to get a spin doctor,
the fact that,
you know,
we know.
And so the rationalizations are just
while we prayed and,
and,
and therefore god saved us,
or this was a test of our faith and god
allowed us to live or,
or my favorite.
The world didn't end.
And this is the new space.
It was a spiritual and dean.
And we're in the new.
That's the loophole that the December
21st,
2012 people.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That one was one of my essay.
Right?
And yeah.
Spiritually in this new beginning,
new beginning.
Yeah.
I had a guy that I had a conversation
with who really was absolutely adamant
that the world was going to change
december 20,
first 2012.
He's like,
it is undeniable.
It's going to happen.
I'm like,
how can you say that?
How can anybody say that?
It's definitely going to happen because
it did change the day,
started getting longer after on December
22nd,
but it's also that the people that came
up with this idea,
their culture doesn't even exist
anymore.
I mean,
you're talking about the mayan
civilization,
wonderful,
spectacular,
advanced civilization that did all this
amazing architecture and they had these
really cool statues that they had built
and really interesting language that was
sort of like hieroglyphic,
you know,
what,
what is it called?
The.
It's a what does the type of language
that they use,
but like where each,
each symbol symbol a symbol simpler,
but each symbol has a certain sound
that's attached to it so you can have
those symbols connected in different
ways.
It's really interesting when there was
a,
I'm a believer as a national geographic
documentary on trying to decode,
I think it was called.
Yeah.
And these guys were,
they were trying to figure out exactly
what these people were writing and how
they wrote it.
Amazing.
I'm actually one of my,
uh,
cycling trading partners.
Nicco his father,
michael coe at yale university.
He was the guy that first crack the
mayan code,
so I blamed his dad for,
for all this end of the world stuff.
Yeah.
Basically it was a.
It was a cyclical,
a time cycle instead of a times arrow
that is these ages repeat themselves in
these long,
long,
long form cycles and that december 20,
first 2012 was to whatever extent it was
coming to an end.
It was just a period of time,
like almost like our year comes to an
end and a new year start.
Alls it is is the calendar is rolling
over the next phase,
the end of the long count for the long
couch and what happened is those people
nothing.
They just quit talking about it.
I mean,
no,
almost no one ever says,
you know what?
I was wrong.
People just sort of drop it and go out.
I'm not into that anymore.
Well,
It was an industry that december,
21st thing was in industry for awhile
and I thought it was awesome.
I loved it.
I thought it was cool.
I even had a license plate and it said
December,
2012.
I had a license plate he did because I
thought it was hilarious.
It is hilarious,
but it's also cool,
like it's kind of fun to think that it's
really going to happen.
Like people have these ideas.
That's when the aliens are going to
return.
That's what we're going to become self
aware.
I think terence mckenna believed that's
when people are going to come up with a
time machine.
It was a bunch of like really
fascinating ideas.
What the hell was going to go down.
But there seems to be this longing that
people have for an event that we're
building towards an event.
Well,
the idea is there's two dueling ideas is
the idea of progress in history and
decline in history.
And so when people write about it,
it's usually we're in a period of
decline.
It's like,
like republicans right now,
you know,
America is the greatest nation ever
except it's in a shit hole.
It's the worst it's ever been now
because of this guy.
But,
but,
but before we're going to return back to
the way it used to be.
Great.
So every generation has this.
Ours is the special generation,
either ours is culminating in this great
thing that's going to happen or things
are terrible,
but if we could get through that,
they were the ones that are going to
come out the other side,
the born again,
you know,
the left behind hers,
uh,
you know,
that,
the christian apocalypse,
you know,
there's plenty of secular versions of
this.
You know,
mark'S has had this idea that,
you know,
the end of capitalism in the beginning
of socialism and communism.
This is a big stage thing.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of science.
Fiction is like this,
it,
it makes a drama better when there's a
beginning point and end point.
We're at this crisis moment and things
are going to be great again or,
or,
or they're going to come to an end and
they'll be great.
But there's always that tension between
decline and progress with is also this
realization that there will be an end
for you.
That we are finite beings.
We have a beginning,
we're born,
we have an end,
we die and it's gonna happen.
So when is it happening?
I don't know what I'm fucking scared.
It's something coming.
Oh,
it's coming.
The apocalypse.
All,
jesus.
Here it is.
And then we find this thing and if
you're really inclined to be gullible,
you know you get sucked into like the
heaven's gate folks think,
well,
the way it's going to happen is there's
a ufo behind this media and what we got
to do is when the comment is near,
we gotta kill ourselves and wear purple
nike's and then we'll live our art bell
has a little bit of culpability in that
because he was promoting the hale bopp
comet ufo theory for quite a while on
his show and they used to listen to that
show and that's when they bought.
They went down and bought a a telescope
and to see if they could see it and
they.
And so I'm in.
I'm not blind to it,
but I got into it by listening to that
theory.
Promoted our bell.
Yeah.
So then when marshall applewhite said,
you know,
I think this is it.
This is all going to come with the comet
and comedy albums and little competition
when it comes to cult leaders,
it seems like once a cult leader has
like that position,
like the,
they very rarely get forced out of the
board,
you know?
No one says,
you know,
what?
Marshall's out of his fucking mind.
I'm not cutting my hair off because they
were treating themselves and you know,
and he was obviously.
So nadine,
like,
did you not have one person in that
group that you might have thought like,
well,
maybe,
maybe mike's got some better ideas in
martial arts and mike doesn't work that
way.
Usually those ones get purged.
Like in the mormon fundamentalist
mormons.
They just purge anybody that wants to
challenge the,
the elite,
the profit.
But so there's a critical point and
every cult when the leader dies a well,
okay,
what happens?
Usually the cults just die with him.
But in the case of scientology,
uh,
wait,
what are you saying?
Scientology is a call.
Sorry.
Whoa,
dude.
We're in hollywood.
I do know that once you watch your
mouth,
you know,
and uh,
uh,
when Joseph Smith was killed,
that could have been the end of the
mormon church,
but bring them young,
took over the reigns.
So if there's another charismatic
leader,
david miscavige and david miscavige took
over from l,
ron,
and he was charismatic and people turn
their,
you know,
they,
they acknowledged him as the,
as the new leader.
And one of my favorite moments in all of
comedy
is when miscavige and tom cruise or on
stage and they salute l ron hubbard,
lrh,
and they saluted.
There was a lot of testosterone and
right there on that stage like,
oh boy,
man,
he's got a big,
gigantic embarrassing.
Not embarrassing at all.
So wonderful to me when this,
the,
the human folly of it all.
You know,
the belief system of anybody that's an
intelligent person by the way,
massively successful,
especially financially,
both of them financially,
but tom cruise culturally massively,
massively successful,
wearing a big gold plate on his neck and
saluting one of the worst science
fiction authors of all time.
I mean,
it is amazing.
Not to mention when he died,
he was,
he was a packed up with antidepressants
and other drugs.
Allegedly.
Again,
it's exactly.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
how about the fact that he lived for a
long time on a boat off the shore
because he owed so much taxes they
couldn't land.
Right.
So like that's where all the c corp and
all that crazy shit.
He wrote more books than anyone who's
ever lived.
He wrote more fiction than anyone ever.
Yep.
A mad fiction.
Horrible fiction.
Right.
Harlan ellison,
who I know is a science fiction writer,
says he was there at the meeting when l
ron.
Well,
the,
the meme is that he said if you really
want to make money writing science
fiction,
you started your own religion,
but actually was according to harlan
ellison is there was a group of them
just sort of sitting around complaining
about the,
the,
the fees that people paid.
Writers.
Like all of us writers complained about
we don't make enough money.
And so that's when somebody said,
well,
you know,
if,
if we started a religion and then
they'll run,
kind of jumped in and said,
yeah,
let's start a really.
And then he actually went out and did
it,
whereas the rest of them,
you know,
they just kept writing science fiction.
have you read a going clear red glow
going clear?
I saw the film,
I mean films good.
Really the nana's because they have time
to go into depth about his past and all
the stuff that transpired before he
created scientology was given these
film,
right?
Alex gibney film and lawrence wright's
book.
That's right.
Yep,
yep.
Yeah,
laWrence.
Right.
It's a great dirt now that's real
investigative journalist when you sink
your teeth into those thing and bold,
right?
Yeah.
And it's amazing.
He got away with it,
you know,
because there are people trying to do
that.
Back in the eighties,
there was a guy from time magazine that
did the cover story with the volcano
erupting on it,
and he was harassed and threatened and
people put stuff in his mailbox and
pizza.
Different world now though,
first of all,
their numbers have drastically declined.
Scientology's numbers have declined and
then on top of that the internet is
exposed it for what it really is.
RIght.
The before we did not like I went to one
of these things in san diego,
but just a few years ago,
I think it was like was say like seven,
seven years ago,
they had one of these things where you
had the e meter and you sat down there
were given a free personality tests and
I sat down and talked to the guys and
they seem kind of like bored and
disinterested and weird,
but you don't see those at all anymore.
You don't see those.
I don't think they even do that anymore.
Oh,
they do?
There's one that well on on hollywood
boulevard right down there,
but building a.
No,
you could.
I've seen he meters on the street.
On the street.
Yep.
Jamie.
Right in front of a chinese theater
after the going.
I asked the guy about that.
Have you seen this movie night and see
that movie all propaganda.
Yeah,
that's right.
I ordered a book late night tv in 1994
dianetics.
I was like,
I was going to Anthony Robbins self help
stuff trying to,
trying to get ahead in this life,
you know,
young man and I ordered that dianetics
book.
Those people never stopped sending me
shit,
never stopped sending me invites and
this.
And did they get the numbers so we have
millions of followers because anybody
that ever,
I guess I'm a farmer on the list or was
it.
Well,
so they don't have my new address.
You can still go clear if you would like
to,
to be clear.
I had a neighbor,
it's a horrible story.
Poor guy,
nice guy.
But his,
um,
I think poem,
I think he still lives down the street,
but anyway,
his um,
there was a plot of land that he wanted
to buy and we were talking about it,
you know,
and he's like,
well we can't do it right now because
nancy's about to go clear.
It was like,
what?
What does that mean?
I didn't know what it meant.
Oh,
you know,
wouLd have been okay.
I,
I only knew this,
you know,
it was probably [inaudible] 98.
I only knew a little bit about
scientology.
It's like,
what do you mean go and clear?
Both were scientologists.
I go going clear how much that cost
$50,000.
$50,000
for like some ceremony.
And I go,
well,
what does it involve?
Well,
she's no longer affected by external
influence,
so once she goes clear,
nothing will bother her.
Like you can say anything to her,
you could insult her and nothing will
get in and she will write.
But that's what everybody wants,
right?
everybody wants this,
this,
the,
the ability to be autonomous,
to be,
they just completely,
completely free of any bullshit in this
life,
this distress and the worry and the
negativity.
So they sell you on that.
Like these are the things you need to
get rid of.
Oh,
I didn't even know.
I mean,
part of the,
he made her thing,
you know,
it's just,
it's just measuring the voltage between
your hands and skin conductance.
Um,
but,
you know,
think about your mother.
Okay?
I'm thinking about my wu spiked because
I squeezed his hand slightly more.
All right,
let's talk about your mind.
well,
everybody has issues with parents with x
levers and spouses and bosses and you
can find something and it's like,
would you like to get rid of that bad?
Well,
you know,
if you go meditate,
you know you go to a buddhist center,
they'll tell you the same thing.
You're focusing on the negative of your
past.
We're going to clear that out by
meditating.
So they're all very various forms of the
same kind of thing.
Like everybody has.
Like the psychic hotlines,
everybody has problems,
love health,
money,
car.
Everybody's got some issue and we're
going to help for
a fee.
Well,
what's fascinating about l ron is it
seems like l rom was nuts.
I shouldn't use the word not.
He had some mental problems,
mental problems,
and it seems like part of what
scientology was,
was his attempt at self help and that
was one of the things that Lawrence
Wright went into that it seems pretty
clear that this guy used all these
available psychological techniques at
the time to try to cure himself self
help thing.
I think a lot of people go into
psychotherapy because they themselves,
oh yeah,
uh,
you know,
have issues that they're dealing with.
When I was in college,
that was the only thing that was
interesting to me.
It was psychology was interesting to me
because I was trying to figure out my
own brain.
I was like,
god,
I got a great fucking thing under,
under wraps being handled.
So that was the,
that was the one thing.
Robin's uh,
you know,
they kind of have a tracking the line
between being a con artist.
He's not but selling something that
could maybe help people maybe.
But if you follow his direction,
I think he,
he's more positive than negative.
I,
I agree.
I mean,
some of this stuff is pretty basic,
you know,
set goals and write them down and don't
get distracted from these things.
Stay focused,
you know,
just pretty basic stuff that actually is
true.
It works if you work at,
and we did a story on the self help
movement and skeptic by a guy wrote a
book called sham,
the self help and actualization movement
and the pr and this guy he used to work
for rodale press,
which is one of the big publishers of
self help books and in the marketing
department said that the number one
predictor of anybody who would buy one
of these self help books is somebody who
had already bought a self help book.
Well,
if they work,
why do you need to keep buying the tapes
and the books and all that stuff.
And the answer is,
is that it?
They only Work temporarily.
Like if you bring tony robbins into your
corporation,
he is for sure going to get your sales
force really motivated,
man,
I'm going to make some common,
make 50 calls a day rather than 30 calls
a day and I'm going to really do this
and they see a spike for a while and
then people go back to their baseline
where they were and that's why you got
to keep listening to the tapes and,
and,
and listening to the music and the books
and all that stuff to kind of keep it
up.
So it only works to a certain extent and
for a limited period of time.
Well it's very difficult for people to
change behavior patterns.
You have this pattern.
They're very comfortable.
It's very hard to change too,
right?
Don't they say it's like 90 days of
doing something all the time for it
becomes a habit.
It's like you can kind of ingrain a new
path probably longer than that.
It's why diets are so difficult to work.
You know,
you have a lifetime of,
you have this fat level and you know
this kind of food your body's used to.
And to shift it,
it,
it's not going to happen in weeks or
months.
He really,
it's a lifestyle change for forever.
It really turned into a dial.
You can commit to a diet for a long
period of time.
But a lot of people in the community,
like I have a,
I'm on a diet
right now for 60 days.
Mark sisson's primal blueprint.
It's like,
it's sort of a ketogenic diet.
Okay.
Based,
um,
mostly hit a lot of fucking avocados.
Dude.
Avocados,
mct oil,
a lot of coconut oil,
almond butter,
a lot of healthy fats.
Like what'd you have for breakfast this
morning?
I have five eggs and avocado.
You did.
So you don't worry about cholesterol?
No.
Yeah,
pussy bro.
I'll be clinton dot clinton lost all
that weight.
Get ready.
Was cardiovascular?
Yeah.
He wouldn't be pended.
What did he do?
He's vegan.
He went vegan is all plants.
He says basically huge salads a twice a
day.
That's just great for you,
period.
That was great.
Great for you.
If you can eat more plants more the
better.
But um,
figure adding more than plants.
So coconut butter and no.
Well,
the idea of systems idea is an system
was a big ultra endurance guy as well.
It's the idea is that your body
functions more efficiently on high fat
content and it does on a high
carbohydrate content.
So it's very low carbohydrate,
no added sugar,
no grains whatsoever,
right?
No pastas,
no.
Here's what's interesting about it.
Um,
the mental clarity aspect of it is
really interesting.
Different.
Yeah.
And I had a few friends that have tried
the same diet and it was one of the
things they pointed out and I think
there's a certain amount of brain fog
that comes from heavy carbohydrate meals
you avoid,
you avoid.
And then once Your body becomes into a
state of ketosis,
which I think takes like 20 something
days or there's,
there's a bunch of different supplements
like see this stuff right here.
This is a keto genic cream.
The product that you can add to coffee,
there's a bunch of different.
That's what you're putting in ketones
now.
That is actually just because this stuff
is coffee with mct oil and grass fed
butter.
Have you ever had that step before?
Is that what it's,
uh,
from um,
robb wolf invention,
he figured out how to add grass fed
butter,
mct oil,
which is a medium chain triglycerides,
essentially the healthiest aspects of
coconut oil.
My headaches gone,
hey,
you feel better?
But um,
it's just a healthy fats and mixed in
with coffee mate.
No,
I'm okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Alright.
But mostly I'm hearing my theory on
diets that they work because you're
doing something,
you're actively involved in keeping
track of how many calories you go in and
you start cutting out the bad foods.
Definitely junk food,
sugars,
grained,
stuff like that.
And they work.
It doesn't matter if it's this
particular one here,
this one,
the air,
it's the doing something about a problem
that that is what really works it.
Well,
I didn't even have a problem.
I did it.
Just try it.
I did it just because I wanted to feel
what it would be like.
Yeah,
try this diet because I had
read about citizen and he's a really
interesting guy and then I'd also
listened to a tim ferris podcast.
Tim ferriss had this great podcast With
dr d'agostino.
I believe his name is who is.
I'm heavily into ketosis ketogenetic
diets and the science behind it.
He's a really,
really brilliant guy and fascinating
podcasts.
we have to listen to it like 10 times in
a row and take notes,
but one of the things that they brought
up,
which is really interesting is the,
the mental benefits of it and the fact
that it helps children with epilepsy
when they put them on a ketogenic diet.
It stops epilepsy in its tracks.
I don't know about that one.
Yeah,
no,
it's a.
This is,
uh,
this is,
I've researched it.
It's really,
really fascinating.
It's one of the main things they do to
children that have child's epilepsy.
Other thing that people do when they get
on dice,
they also start exercising,
which has other benefits.
That's tons of benefits.
But I did that already too.
So for me it was,
it was just wanting to try,
want to try it for the athletic benefit,
wanting to try it for the physical
benefit.
But I lost a lot of body fat.
You did?
Yeah.
And I wasn't fat,
but I definitely could have lost a
little bit of weight,
you know,
but I mean not compared to like I still
have a six pack,
like you can see my abs before I did it,
but I lost 10 pounds.
Now I'm down to one.
I think it was one 93 this morning and I
was somewhere around two.
Oh four before.
Okay.
It's kinda kinda fascinating.
And well,
will you have for lunch?
Um,
it's,
it depends,
but no grains.
That's the big one.
The big one is no grains,
no pasta.
No.
You know,
just very low carbs.
Like I'm getting my protein from mostly
wild game.
Mostly a elk and deer and things along
those lines while hunting here.
Shoot your ass.
I don't necessarily do it all here.
It's hard.
No.
Santa monica canoga park.
That's not really a lot of meat to you
if you had out here walking around,
but I do.
But when you shoot an elk,
you get hundreds of pounds of meat to
commercial freezers in the backfield.
Well,
yeah,
you live nearby.
I'll give you some.
Okay.
It's delicious.
It'S great for you too.
All rIght.
You know,
it's organic.
One hundred percent free of any
antibiotics like bullshit buffalo and
fosterage.
Ostrich meat is very,
very,
very good for it.
Very lean and healthy and it's a rich,
dark red meat filled with iron and
nutrients.
But,
um,
the idea behind it is that you get your
body to burn fat instead of
carbohydrates because that's primarily
with human.
that's why it's not to be confused.
Like the problem with the whole concept
of paleo,
you know,
the paleo diet,
well,
the term can be debunked pretty easily
because they say,
well,
in the paleolithic period,
people ate a lot of bread,
they eat a lot of state,
whatever they could find.
Yes,
yes.
And,
and,
and most hunter gatherers,
most of their calories come from the
gathering part,
not the hunting part.
It's hard to hunt animals.
They don't want to be killed.
So it's,
especially back then they shitty bows
and arrows and they didn't have guns was
very difficult unless you stumbled upon
a herd of blind buffalo,
throw a spear out.
Right?
It's not that easy.
No,
I mean it's,
it's difficult today.
Defined,
really healthy.
I mean if you wanna,
if you want to hunt it yourself,
good luck.
It's a lot of effort.
Right.
You know,
and if you want to actually find really
healthy meat other than grass fed beef,
their options are pretty severely.
What about alcohol?
Do you drink?
Very little because every now and then,
but there's sugar in that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It converts to sugar.
Well the idea is that cookies and ice
cream,
because that's got sugar is gone.
So the dairies.
Okay.
milk a.
Hey,
you can have belt,
but I'm not really sure.
I've never liked milk cookies,
but since I'm not eating cookies and
milk.
Yeah.
Milk guy.
I don't mind raw milk and milk.
I like,
I felt like homogenized and pasteurized
milk.
Once you do that,
I mean it's great as far as you could
store it in a store and it lasts for a
long time,
but you're cooking out all the enzymes.
Right?
It's just not the best thing for your
body.
Yup.
Problem also is if you don't do that
then it's only good for a couple of
days,
so.
Right.
ThAt's.
And you get sick and eggs.
Good.
I'm glad to hear that.
I like eggs.
Eggs are good for you,
man.
Yeah.
Eggs aren't bad and certain amount of
cholesterol is actually important for
your body.
Produce testosterone.
This actually,
you know,
for cellular growth.
Right?
So and eggs,
the one I get from my chickens,
I have chickens.
You do?
Yeah.
That's great.
That's good.
Good for you.
It's 22 chickens.
What about supplements?
That takes up my fish oil,
multivitamins,
omega,
omega six to three.
Yeah,
it took a lot of.
That is something that can go too far or
something like ray kurzweil it takes to.
Oh yeah,
supplements a day,
but he's just trying to stay alive and
terrorist.
Sheens take right now.
I know I interviewed him for example,
he's kind of a girl.
He's almost like a secular guru because
he's constructed this,
you know the second coming is coming,
the singularity,
it's 20,
30,
20,
41,
42.
If you could make it till the year 20,
47 or 2014.
I went to a conference in,
it was the same for the same show for
um,
uh,
joe rogan questions,
everything.
We went to New York and they had this
big conference.
I interviewed him and said,
oh,
the singularity summit.
Yeah.
Well I don't remember.
I think it was 20 slash 40 something.
Whatever the fuck it is,
20,
40.
They just pick a day when they think
that it's all going to happen.
But they had this,
a russian billionaire character who
would develop some artificial,
some thing that,
you know,
he was uh,
gonna unveil that was like a robot of
him.
It's going to be an artificial
intelligence,
but it wasn't ready,
you know,
say even if thAt will come eventually I
think.
But even if they did accomplish that,
would it be you or just a copy of.
You see,
like when you go to sleep and you wake
up,
you're a little groggy,
but there's a continuity.
It's still your memories and your
personal life.
When you go under general anesthesia,
you're groggy after you wake up and it's
still,
there's a continuity,
but if they shut off your brain and turn
it back on inside a computer,
would you wake up and go,
oh,
well,
okay,
this is like waking up or would it just
be you're gone and it's just a copy and
this copy's just functioning completely
on its own and it has no idea what it's
doing because it's not connected to
biology.
It's not connected to all the same.
it should,
you know,
maybe there's like a leap of faith they
have to make before they hit the switch.
I'm not sure that that.
I think the problem of identity is a
serious one for people in terms of
longevity,
in terms of immortality will not only
that.
How about the fact that if I can make
one,
michael shermer,
if I can copy you have one or I just
spam you when I spam you all over europe
have a million.
Michael shermer is all throughout India.
That's,
that's a real problem,
right?
I mean,
if you can mAke a copy,
if you want to be immortal and you want
a copy,
what's to stop someone from making
multiple copies with you?
Stop Donald Trump and right?
Well,
so far nobody.
But if he wants to make a bunch of
donald trump's maniac was just the
moment you turn on the new copy,
uh,
they start having different memories
because they're in a different
environment than a different body and
they're having different interactions.
And so if it's a bioLogical system,
then there's new neural connections
growing that are different than yours
than the joe rogan copy.
So that's no longer you,
you might have the same past memories,
but you're now going to have different.
Just like twins.
Yes.
Nobody thinks twins are identical in
person in personhood illegally.
They're treated as separate entities.
And,
and of course that is right.
So I think that's really what,
what copies a ai copies will be.
It's just like twins.
That's a good point.
Also,
the good point is from here on out,
you're going to have different life
experiences.
So if you made it an exact duplicate of
yourself at this day,
but one went to New York and the other
one moved to miami,
you have totally different lives,
totally different experiences,
totally different blends going to be
liberal,
one's going to be conservative,
you're going to make different
conclusions based on your life
experiences,
and that's just the reality of being a
person is that we're constantly
accumulating data and processing it and
then also it's the environment that you
surround yourself with as far as the
unique individuals that you choose to
associate with.
They flavor who you are so much.
RIght.
It's almost inseparable.
It's so.
It's so difficult to look at a person as
an individual because every individual
is profoundly influenced by all the
other people around them.
Right?
So you take this individual,
you move them to montreal and you
surround them with a bunch of people
that are totally different from them.
They learned french,
they started speaking with the quebecois
and next thing you know they're there.
It does a totally different human being.
Right?
You become different because of the
People that you're around.
Exactly.
You know,
you don't even exist in a vacuum,
right?
So,
so in terms of like trying to achieve in
mortality,
like the military ones or the
transhumanists,
um,
or the extropians,
they're against entropy.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
What's their theory?
It's a little bit
like the transhumanist that we're going
to slowly replace our body parts and in
now,
not just new joints,
but you know,
if you would replace your nerve cells
and as long as you still have to have
the continuity,
it's still you as a person in there.
I'm just uploading it to another
platform.
Is,
is.
I don't think it's going to do it.
I think it's not you anymore.
The johnny depp inside the computer.
Turn it on.
Transcendence theory is.
I don't think that can happen right now.
I may be wrong.
There are people that do think this can
happen but doesn't have to be you.
Can it be like something you,
you personally one,
right?
It'S like woody allen said,
I don't want to live on through my work
I want to live on,
in my apartment.
Uh,
somebody said one of his many lines
about immortality.
Yes.
Um,
you inside the computer,
the copy of you,
a copy of you is just the extension of
your work,
you know,
it's like,
this is a little bit of a copy of me,
my books and so on,
but it's not me.
Right.
and after I'm gone,
the books are still around,
but it's not really me.
I don't feel like I'm still going.
Isn't there a problem with,
if you believe in evolution,
which I assume you do and you,
you assume that people are going to
continue to change shape,
we're going to continue.
I mean if we used to be multicell
organisms that are coming out of the
muck,
the primordial ooze and now were people,
what,
what are we going to be a million years
from now?
are we going to stifle that and just
lock ourselves into this form?
This is not a perfect form.
One of the arguments is that we should,
we should take over evolution and we
are.
so genetic engineering for examPle,
right now everybody's afraid of,
oh,
they're going to make ariens or
whatever.
Okay,
let's just,
let's just allow it to happen to solve
alzheimer's,
cure cancer,
things like that.
Then we can worry about uploading,
you know,
more intelligence into our cortex.
Say for,
for what if we do to people what we've
done to tomatoes,
make them boring and flavor,
flavor,
flavor to last longer.
That could happen.
that's actually a good point.
People,
we did tomatoes,
we fucked up tomatoes,
but they last forever.
Well,
in a way with international travel in
the internet now,
you know the poorest borders in
centuries or so,
you know,
everyone will look like tiger woods or
something like this,
you know,
I think the racial barriers will
eventually dissolved.
Well then we'll find some new way to
hate each other.
Oh,
absolutely.
You know,
humans are super good at that,
but if we colonize another planet,
say we started colony on mars in,
in a way that's a founder population
that can then begin to diverge away from
the earthly population and in a million
years you'd have two different species.
Say they could maybe,
well they'd probably still be able to
integrate because there's still
connections.
You'd also have a movable men that
you've got a whole civilization to
people so fucking crazy.
They decided to move to mars.
It's a self selecting group.
They're probably.
They're probably not typical.
Definitely not.
I mean,
and they're also going to have to do
some crazy geoengineering and we're
going to have to hope that that keeps it
fun.
Scenario would be what kind of
government would they set up?
What kind of economic system and
assuming they were,
none of them were religious.
If he came back a thousand years from
now,
would they have a shrine to a god and
religion and all this.
It happened again and then we'd have the
history archetype a.
It'd be interesting.
It's one of the interesting things about
scientology in the mormon church is that
we have a clear recent history and a
paper trail to see what happened.
Videos,
but we don't have,
but we don't have for christianity is
that it's old enough that it's lost in
the murkiness of time and it so you can
kind of fill in the blanks with miracles
and things like that.
Here we know Joseph Smith was killed and
then brigham young move to Utah to get
away from the authorities and you know,
and we know exactly how it all unfolded
and so you can diagram how to start a
religion.
well,
you know the whole mitt romney story
too,
but his family in Mexico,
right?
Oh right,
that's right.
Yes,
I forgot about that.
Yeah,
I'll move to Mexico when they couldn't
have 100 wives.
Right.
Like,
fuck this.
We're out of America.
Swears his dad bringing me on was
originally against polygamy until.
Yeah,
until he tried it and then he's like,
oh,
well,
one of my favorite books is john
krakauer is under the banner of heaven.
He's a great writer,
but he has a.
He kind of reconstructs the moment when
Joseph Smith tells his wife emma that he
got this revelation from god about
polygamy.
Celestial marriage.
He called it and it basically is already
having an affair with this woman down
the street.
So basically he goes,
well honey,
you know,
I was talking to god and he told me that
I'm supposed to have sex with so and so.
I know I couldn't believe it either,
but my friends,
they were all there.
They heard it too.
They're telling their wives right now.
Oh.
So ama says something like,
well,
in that case I'm going to have a extra
husbands.
He said,
now you know,
god was really clear about this.
It's just for the guys as this gets sold
as a viable,
a declaration of,
of,
of revelations.
And it's written down.
So if you look at the first page of the
book of mormon,
it's an affidavit,
you know,
we are the people.
We saw the gold tablets and so on.
Same thing with the revelation about
polygamy all the way until 18,
94 when the state of Utah wanted to
become a state.
And the federal government said not with
polygamy.
And suddenly they got a new revelation
from god changed my mind about the
polygamy thing back to monogamy.
Oh,
okay,
okay.
It could be a state,
not mitt romney's parents.
They're like,
we're out of here.
So you go to the fringes.
Well,
Colorado city and that was in the news
yesterday.
Um,
apparently the whole police force,
the courts,
everybody that lives in this town is
fundamentalist mormon.
They're polygamous fan.
So you,
Colorado cities.
That's right on the border of Utah and
Arizona,
Colorado city,
Arizona.
I think art,
maybe it's in Utah,
it's right on that road that goes to
kayak and um,
and we've been there.
We race across America.
used to go through on a route to get to
New York.
We'd go through northern Arizona in
southern Colorado.
Did they tell you?
And it's a,
it's a community.
You
drive through there and people are
looking at you and it's like,
it's like being in a twilight zone or
spiles episode,
you know,
where they drive somewhere.
It's like everybody's a little weird and
you can see the dress.
Clothing is like,
everything is off a little bit.
Even like at the gas station,
at the denny's,
it's like there's something not quite
right here.
That's awesome.
I want to go.
Oh,
it's right now.
It's really a.
Yeah.
I don't think the polygamy should be
illegal.
I really don't because it's not illegal
to live with 20 women.
If you just you who hugh hefner it and
you decided to have like 20 women live
with you,
you're a king,
you know,
but if you signed paperwork with them,
then all of a sudden it's a problem.
Well,
the way they do it as they marry one of
them legally and then the rest are so
called sister wives and they're not
actually married to them so they're not
breaking the law and there's no law
against having,
you know,
living with a bunch of women.
It's okay,
well the law only exists in terms of all
the other people outside of their
community or their neighborhood or their
family recognizing it and it's just a
problem with if every.
If you have a law that says this,
but everybody in the town,
including the police captain,
the courts,
well the judge,
they're all in on it.
They're all in it.
So now I have conflicting feelings
about,
about my libertarian tendencies.
We go,
well,
adult people should do whatever they
want,
but why is the government in the
marriage business in the first place?
I agree,
but the problem is when you study the
polygamous mormons,
you know they.
These,
these are young girls,
this warren jeffs,
jessica.
He was marrying twelve-year-olds.
He was having sex with 11 year olds.
Okay.
There is a proBlem.
That's absolutely a problem.
Yeah.
Well that's just a problem period with
someone who's a grown adult who's having
sex with a young kid.
That's obviously that goes without
saying,
but as long as the person's 21 or
whatever,
I mean,
I really think he should probably be 21
before you even allowed to get married.
I mean,
I probably would have got married if I
was 18.
My girlfriend when I was 18 at the time
said,
marry me.
I'm breaking up with you.
I'd be like,
fuck it.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
I was lost.
Yeah,
you're too young.
You don't have enough information to be
allowed to do anything until they're 30.
Probably not even might be fortunate,
but the idea that you could tell some
adult that they can't sign a piece of
paper with another adult.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's just as preposterous to say the
same sex marriage should be illegal,
right?
Why not?
Who cares?
As long as they're not brainwashed when
they're little that they should be.
Yes,
because then maybe you're 21.
Are you really making a rational choice
about your future or are you there?
That becomes a problem with cults and
that's also the problem,
and then it becomes,
okay,
well where's the line?
Get gray.
Okay,
if a mormon can't do it,
if you can't take someone when they're
really young,
raise them as a mormon and then wants to
become of age and they become an adult.
Tell them now you can get married and
you can be involved in this polygamous
marriage and well,
they grew up in this religion.
Are they brainwash even though they're
are grown adult?
Well,
if that's the case,
but what
about alice ism or whatever and you go,
it's the government can't be in the
business of judging that.
so it's a,
it's a,
you know,
it's a fine line there.
It's tough when you put your hand on the
bible when you swear to be in a fucking
president.
Right?
Hilarious weakens bible it still
lincoln's bible.
Well,
that's who obama used was the lincoln's
bible.
Yeah.
No,
I am i.
Am I remembering that was at martin
luther king's bible?
No,
I think it was.
Mlk is bible.
Yeah.
Anyway.
So,
but yeah,
that's very telematic.
We're touching the past.
So dumb as if,
you know,
the old testament is a font of moral
wisdom.
Is it the old testament they use?
Well,
the whole thing,
but is it the new testament,
the old testament that he puts his hand
on?
It's both.
It's the bible that includes both that
polygamy was,
you know,
all the great patriarchs.
There was a study by Helen Fisher now.
It was a different anthropologist on um,
uh,
the relationshiP between power and sex
in the old testament and basically the
more power you had more women and wives
and girlfriends and concubines and
children you had,
how unusual.
And solomon was the,
you know,
he was going for wilt chamberlains
record there.
He had 700 wives,
300 concubines,
and you know,
thousands of kids,
I guess.
Well,
allegedly,
but I mean,
it wasn't,
no,
uh,
600 years old.
So it's hard,
right?
I mean,
most of the stuff probably didn't
actually happen in the old testament.
Probably moses never existed,
but the point is that,
that is the way men treated women,
that,
that was the patriarchal society at the
time.
Slavery was legal,
polygamy was legal.
The more power you had,
the more wealth you had,
the more women you have,
the more children you had it.
That was the world of the old testament,
you know,
and that's not the world we live in now.
So why are we still using this book?
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
it's,
nobody would embrace,
you know,
christian today,
I would embrace most of the stuff that's
in the bible.
They just wouldn't.
So when they say I get my morals from
the bible,
it's like,
no,
you don't.
And that's a good thing.
You're getting your morals from the same
place.
We nonbelievers get it.
Uh,
and you know,
we were inculcating it from culture,
from the enlightenment secular values.
Well,
I'm glaD you brought that up because
that was an article that I've read that
you had written about islam,
that islam was the only religion that
had not gone through the advertisement.
Right?
Yeah.
I think that was a really,
really interesting article and a very
important point.
You know what I mean?
Christianity,
they used to be head jews,
uh,
and witches were burned at the stake,
you know,
I mean the kinds of stuff isis does
today.
Christians used to do that centuries
ago.
It's very common and they stopped.
Why?
Well,
the law changed.
That culture changed and the
enlightenment era ushered in secular
values that all people should be treated
equally under the law that people are
born with equal rights and,
and,
and so forth.
And,
and that all changed everything and
everybody is incorporate.
Just thinking about,
I'm a member when the owners,
a former owner,
the clippers,
donald sterling made these remarks,
you know,
but most old guys thought like that just
50 years ago and weren't particularly.
His remarks were pretty,
pretty innocuous.
What he has said,
he had a girlfriend,
this is,
this thing has been blown out of
proportion so bad and yet he had a
girlfriend and he asked her not to take
pictures with these guys.
These black guys.
He said in the same sentence,
you can fuck them.
I don't care if you fuck them,
just don't take pictures with them.
It was already said.
Yeah,
they need to clear that part.
Print any of that.
Right.
And everybody was talking about the the
don't take pictures of the black eyes.
He said he knew what he was saying was
that you're sticking it in my face that
you're fucking on these guys.
I don't care if you fuck them.
Just don't take pictures of.
I don't want to see it.
Right.
Saying this to his girlfriend in the
privacy of his house.
He didn't use any racial slurs.
He didn't say anything terrible.
All he said was,
don't take pictures of these guys
because she was a slow.
Allegedly,
she's banging a bunch of dudes and he
didn't care because he's like 80 years
old.
He's like buying or condos and rolls
royces and shit.
He just,
he just wants to keep banging her
because she's hot,
right?
So he's like,
I don't care for him.
Look,
you're still have higher standards.
That guy's,
he looks like jabba the hutt.
He's like,
his face has fallen off his bones.
Right.
So for that poor guy,
I mean that last him,
his,
his team,
which is insane.
But it shows you how far we've come.
And again,
most people,
most old guys in the fifties would have
thought nothing about saying that
publicly.
Yeah.
But apparently he was pretty racist and
that what they caught him with a small
little slice of what he had done.
This is obviously allegedly blah blah
blah.
But apparently it wasn't a nice guy,
which is why this was so reinforced and
why people went after him so hard.
They're like,
look,
we got him which has run with this and
obviously it's a pr nightmare,
but yeah,
people evolve.
And I think now in today's day and age,
that kind of thinking like racist
thinking justifiably so is gross.
It's frowned upon absolute learning we
are learning yet.
Yeah.
So I mean the moral arc,
that's what that's about tracking,
you know,
how much moral progress we've made over
the centuries,
particularly just the last 50 years and
the civil rights movement.
It's one reason why I think all these
campus protests,
I've gotten so out of hand there so
disproportionate because the students
have a moral,
a module there still passionate about
making the world a better place,
but all the big stuff's been taken.
It's all done.
Did it down to halloween costumes,
taco tuesdays,
he wore a sombrero.
Cultural appropriate,
you know,
they're all fired up about what they
view it as just like safe spaces.
That's where ideas go to die.
I mean,
come on.
It's safe spaces such such a stupid
argument.
Any argument that's worth it,
it has to stand on its own merits.
You have to be able to discuss things
like having a university where you can't
discuss ideas,
would even even bad ideas.
Bad ideas should be debated.
The idea that they won't let these
conservatives perform or speeches at the
universities and they tried to shut them
down,
scream at people.
They.
They hit fire alarms.
I mean,
it's madness.
It's,
it's everything that you're not supposed
to do when you're defending and
exploring ideas.
I think the deeper,
the deepest cause of this is,
is the asymmetry between left and right
on,
in the academy?
Yes.
It's in some of these departments.
It's 20 to one,
a liberal conservative democrat,
republican,
uh,
only in the economics department.
The social sciences.
do you get something like a balance
everywhere else it's super slanted.
And uh,
so you're,
you're,
you're getting this added.
Well,
we know what the truth is.
maybe you don't know what the truth is
and you need to listen to the other side
because that's what has driven science
and reason and the enlightenment is,
is open open debate because I might not
be right.
And so the only way to find out is if I
ask you your opinion.
And so I tell my students,
you know,
you gotta,
you gotta read the wall street journal
in addition to the New York times,
you got to listen to,
you know,
conservative talk radio in addition to
npr and you gotta you gotta hear it,
you know,
he listened to rush limbaugh.
Oh god,
I know he's a knuckle dragging a mouth
breather.
But somebody on that side just to see
what listening to larry elder there.
I like larry elder.
Yeah,
he's a conservative,
but he's a little bit more rational.
Lot more,
little more libertarian arguments are
interesting.
Yeah.
And the only way to know what the other
side really thinks because you think,
well why do they believe that?
Well,
you have to listen to their arguments to
at least be able to articulate why
they're wrong.
If you can't do that,
then you really don't know why they're
wrong.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And find,
try to like balance,
like look at things through their
perspective.
Even if you don't agree with their
perspective,
just relax yourself,
relax yourself and allow you.
Allow yourself To explore the way they
think.
You know,
I,
I follow a bunch of wackadoos on twitter
just so I can listen to them read their
stuff.
I follow this one guy,
he's a young earth christian who,
uh,
every day we'll talk about how horrible
obama obama's the death in this country
and I will follow this guy and follow
people who retweet him and go to their
links and go to their blogs,
read their blog or what the fuck just
because I'm just trying to explore how
their mind works,
trying to try to piece together how much
of it is just a bold blanket hatred of
liberals.
How much of it is racism,
how much of it is this,
how much of it is that?
And just trying to objectively assess
where their mindset is and what the root
of their thinking is.
That's what I did back in the nineties
when the holocaust denial movement
started taking off and uh,
these guys were appearing on montel
williams and donahue and was like,
what?
Okay,
what is this about?
Turns out they're in their offices in
costa mesa.
So I drove down there and I just sat
down with the.
They have a little journal of historical
review and it's like,
all right,
who are these guys?
So we had beer and pizza,
you know,
I just started to get them to open up
with,
what is your story here?
right.
That's the only way to find out what
they're,
what's really behind their arguments.
okay.
They have these arguments,
here's why they're wrong.
Okay,
but why are they making these arguments?
The only way to find out is actually
talked to them and why were they making
their arguments if some of it's at pure
antisemitism,
but also there's some conspiratorial
thinking,
you know,
the jews are doing this but not just the
jews,
you know,
the media that this.
And that is one of those exposing the
mystery thing because it's a little bit
of that,
you know,
the government,
they don't want us to know.
They like,
wait,
who's the thing?
Because that's us,
right?
Uh,
well no,
they have the super power and you know,
so there's a lot of that behind there.
And then also there's some,
you know,
basically I can get attention by saying
this wacko back,
the wackadoodle kind of stuff and then
people pay attention to me and that
feels good and so I'll run with it.
No,
david irvine was there,
a big intellectual and uh,
he,
he was self trained historian but also a
pretty smart guy,
good writer.
And he wrote some,
his early stuff on,
on gerbils and,
and some of the stuff on the second
world war was,
was,
was quite good.
But then he found he wasn't in the
academies,
self-taught and just published his own
books and kind of made a living doing
that.
And he found that when he started
migrating toward this,
you know,
maybe hitler didn't know about the
holocaust and it was really gerbils and
himmler and they're the ones that did it
and hitler didn't know.
You've all of a sudden he gets all this
attention and then he,
he concocts this idea of I'll give a
thousand dollars to anybody that can
show me the order from hitler to,
to orchestrate the holocaust.
You know,
I hereby command,
we exterminate the jews.
Okay.
There is no such order,
there's no single point.
It's a whole conglomerate of little
steps along the way from sterilization
of the feebleminded in the early
thirties all the way up to gassing them.
Okay.
There's like a hundred steps in between
so there is no single order,
but that got him all this attention and
all of a sudden he's a big star at these
conferences where these people meet.
so I went to some of these and it's
like,
whoa,
okay.
He is being worshiped as this great
scholar and and you could sort of see
how it fed,
fed the ego,
get a lot of attention.
So I think that we can't discount it.
Just appear psychology of getting some
attention for your views as pushing
people further than they would normally
go.
Yeah,
I think that'S a very,
very good point because there's a,
there's a massive attraction to that is
people are massively attracted to
anything that can get them a lot of
attention.
Even for a ridiculously controversial
idea.
Have you paid attention lately and this
is one of the most confusing things
that's been going on.
There's a gang of people that believe
the earth is flat.
Oh yes.
They're paying attention to this.
I saw that.
Yes.
I can't believe that in 2016,
this is really a thing.
If there is a movement that believes
that all of the iss pictures,
those are all fake and that all the
pictures are just getting attention and
nothing more.
Do you think they really believe I've
watched some videos.
these fucking people bullying.
Yeah.
I have a friend who believes it was
loosely based friend.
Max everly,
you're out there.
You fuck.
He's a fantastic pool player,
but he's out of his fucking mind.
He blog postings about it on facebook.
I'm like,
max,
have a conversation with them.
Here's a.
Here's a good example of why we need
free speech.
You know,
these people should not be centered.
Let them say what they want to say and
let's,
let's show how we do know the earth is
round.
Let's see.
Can you articulate five reasons why the
earth is?
Why don't you tell max aberly why the
earth is located?
Okay,
max,
here's the deal.
All right,
so first of all,
uh,
when there's an eclipse,
you can see the shadow of the earth on
the moon.
The lunar eclipse.
there it is,
it's current.
That's the government with a projector.
Yeah.
But,
but you can go out in your own backyard
with no good.
Okay.
NoW what they'll say is,
yeah,
it's round like a pizza flat round.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
But of course,
if that were true,
then why are all the continents?
Uh,
you know,
why aren't all the continents located on
the one side of the pizza?
And if they're on the flip side,
how do you get from one continent to
another when you do a transcontinental
flight?
Because it,
it,
you're curving around it.
You're not all of a sudden hitting an
edge and then flipping around to the
backside of the pizza.
And so there's a second reason,
uh,
if you,
if you're high up and you look out,
you can see the mass of a ship sailing
away.
The whole goes first and then you see
the mass last because it's curved and
it.
Anyway.
So there's all these.
If you put a stick here and 500 miles
away,
make it.
I dunno,
a tucumcari New Mexico that's a thousand
miles from la.
You put a stick there at noon,
at the same time they'll have different
shadows because the earth is curved,
so they're good at 12 noon.
It's actually 1:00
in New Mexico when it's 12 noon in la
and that's why we have time zones
because it's curved.
Okay.
And so,
and when you,
when you want to watch a rocket,
a space x rocket or nasa rocket launch
from Florida,
it arcs.
It's arcane because it's going into
orbit and the earth is curved so you
have to arch out.
Otherwise it would just go straight up
and it doesn't do that anyway.
Those are five different,
you know,
quick reasons is pretty good.
But you sound like a shill for this
round bullshit government.
There was a,
uh,
the kind of the co-discovered natural
selection with darwin guy named alfred
Russell Wallace.
He was nuts.
He was way out there.
I wrote my biography on him and he came
up with a dream that connected darwin's
theories together.
Like is darwin's theories and his
theories came together like darwin had a
problem,
right?
With natural selection.
Who's trying to figure out how to piece
it all together.
He does.
His ideas were not quite there.
There is a conspiracy theory about that,
that,
that darwin cribbed from,
uh,
from wallace,
I don't think that's the case,
what it is for them,
but that they sort of combined the
simultaneous thing and they were in
correspondence.
Wallace actually incorporated some of
darwin's work.
Darwin was older than him and he had
already done quite a bit more work than
wallace head.
And in any case,
wallace was super open minded.
So here's an example of being too open
minded in darwin was open and he came up
with new ideas,
but he's also very skeptical of the
whole spiritual seance movement that was
getting big in england.
Walsh's wallace,
he would go to these seances and hold
the hands and the table would levitate
in darwin.
people don't hear about darwin.
We'd just like,
I'm not going to us say,
are you fucking kidding me?
I mean,
this is insane.
And Thomas Henry huxley,
the other great scientists said,
you know,
pay,
pay five shillings to talk to bottle to
the dead.
I mean,
come on,
but wallace,
oh no,
I'm going,
this is,
this might be true.
And uh,
so he was in and then he made the
mistake of answering an ad in a magazine
for a,
of one of these flat earthers who said,
I give fight,
you know,
5,000
pounds to 500 pounds,
I guess it was.
Anybody can prove the earth is round.
So what year was this?
This was 18.
This was the 18,
a psa.
18 eighties.
And so while I said,
okay,
I can do it.
So they went to the old bedford canal,
which is like 20 miles straight without
a band.
So you could set up two little
telescopes,
you know,
those little survey or telescopes.
And they put a mark on a bridge.
Okay.
And so when I'm looking.
So there's one,
two,
three marks.
If it's straight,
then it should be all lined up.
If it's curved than the one here.
That's exactly three feet above the
ground.
Like this one here,
that's five miles down the road,
down the canal,
it,
it should be lined up.
Or if it's not,
it's dropped a little bit.
And in five miles you could actually
measure a little bit of the earth's
curve by like,
I don't know,
it's like a centimeter,
half a centimeter or something.
Right?
There it is,
right?
There it is.
There's the old bedford canal.
So wallace did that and they had a
neutral judge who looked through the
telescope and said,
yep,
it's curved,
it's dropped.
And,
and this guy that flatter,
if they refuse to look through the,
I'm not going to look through there.
I know you're wrong.
And uh,
and wallace,
he,
so he had to sue this guy to collect the
prize money.
This is why you shouldn't get involved
with a wackadoodle people too far
because he spent 15 years dealing with
this guy and this guy was sending crazy
letters to his wife and to the natural
geographical.
I actually found some of these letters
that the national geographical society,
uh,
this guy threatening,
you know,
you've got this crazy man wallace
working for it.
And so on,
you know,
these,
some of these people are,
they're a little mentally,
as you know,
a changed.
That's fascinating.
But wallace,
his ideas converged with darwin's ideas
and it kind of helped darwin's theory
would disown them eventually.
No,
no.
What,
what,
what really happened was it accelerated
darwin to get his work done.
So you get the book done.
He was just sort of lollygagging around
doing his research.
And one reason for that is I'm in 18,
44,
there was a book on evolution published
called the vestiges of creation.
It was published anonymously and it was
trashed by the scientific community.
So,
so darwin got back from the galapagos in
18,
36 throughout the 1840.
He was just taking notes,
composing his ideas,
running experiments.
You've got married and had 10 kids.
And he was the,
he had a lot of money invested in the
railroad.
So he was a pretty active independent
scholar.
And uh,
and so I just started taking his sweet
time about developing this theory and
also he didn't want to be embarrassed
and come out with a book that wasn't
very solid.
And then he would be criticized,
so he was just compiling anyway,
one day he gets this letter from wallace
from the other side of the world is in
the malaya archipelagos.
I came up with a few ideas that he had
like a feverish nightmare from malaria.
And he hatched this natural selection.
Some species compete with others as the
populations increase in a and way.
Uh,
and so not all of them can survive.
Some will survive.
Differential reproductive success,
natural selection.
Boom.
So he outlines this to darwin.
Darwin is reading this going,
oh crap,
this is my idea.
I mean,
he,
he sort of outlined like my book.
So then he rushed into print.
It's like I gotta get this done.
So they weren't necessarily
collaborating.
They weren't exactly collaborating,
although they had communicated.
And also darwin,
not only was wallace not upset about
this,
he was thrilled.
He wrote his mom and said,
oh my god,
the great charles darwin wrote me back.
This is so cool.
And then darwin went to charles lyell
and some of the other big scientists at
the time and said,
I got this letter from,
from this guy on the other side and you
know,
I've been working on this.
This is really similar and uh,
what do I do?
So they said,
alright,
we'll publish both of them
simultaneously.
And they did on July 1st 18,
58 at the linnean society.
They both presented both papers,
some of darwin's notes and,
and essays he had written in wallaces,
no letter to darwin with a little
handwritten paper.
And they entered in both into the record
the same day,
july,
first 18,
58,
boom,
simultaneous discovery,
wallace darwin.
Then spent the next basically nine
months.
Just the pen moves mighty fast when
you're afraid you're going to get
scooped,
right?
Right.
And he goT his book done.
Boom,
november 18 slash 59 origin species.
The rest is history.
And wallace,
he wrote again,
is,
oh my god,
this is so exciting.
You know,
I'm part of this great movement.
And then only later,
much,
much later did other people start to
think,
you know,
he ripped you off and,
and he's like,
nah,
it's [inaudible].
Wallace wrote his great book in 18
eighties called darwinism.
So what's really fascinating that he
came up with that theory based on a
dream from being in a fever state.
Yep.
How amazing it went.
Well,
but that often,
you know,
the spark of a scientific genius or
creativity in any field.
I was taking a shower and boom,
the idea came to me.
I was on a walk.
So there's some theories about this that
if you think too hard and focused on a
specific problem,
you can't.
You have to sort of relax your brain,
whatever that means by doing something
else that's non focused meditation,
taking a shower,
going for a walk,
going for a bike ride,
in my case,
anything that's just sort of not
thinking about the problem and that we
don't know what happens.
Maybe some neurons just started to start
firing and interacting.
Different neural networks.
This memory of that,
this memory of that,
this book,
you read,
this thing you saw on the internet,
boom,
they come together.
But yeah,
we don't know how that happens.
It's this writers like to do that.
They like to write and then they go for
a walk,
right?
And then after the they're,
you know,
they're done writing,
they go walk and they try not to think
about anything and then the ideas will
just pop into their head or a correction
and the idea or a new revelation and the
idea.
Yeah,
it's just always been amazing to me.
Ideas that come out of dreams,
like the origins of creativity,
like where are these thoughts emanating
from what?
Like descartes,
like the idea of science came from a
dream,
the dream of uh,
you know,
being in an elevator,
if you're in an elevator and the
elevator drops at just the speed of
gravity and you let go of your pin or
your coffee mug,
it's just kinda hover there like you're
hovering inside the elevator as it
drops.
So thE,
so the acceleration of the elevator at
the speed of gravity means there's no
gravity and that's where he came up with
this idea of relativity in the elevator
is the frame of reference that you and
the cup or in.
And so this is what weightlessness is
when you're,
when you do the vomit comet,
basically lg as you go up high enough to
drop.
And so the plane is plunging down for
about a minute or two,
I guess I've never done it.
And you and the camera and whoever else
is in there is just floating because the
whole frame is dropping.
And so to do this in,
on the space shuttle for example,
it has to go,
what?
Seventeen thousand 500 miles an hour to
maintain,
uh,
the same speed at which accelerating at
which it would also drop.
So you're going straightforward and
straight down.
The halfway in between is 17,500
miles an hour for our planet.
That's,
that's basically it.
I create zero gravity.
So if you want to go to mars and,
and,
and have some gravity,
you just spin the spaceship.
So that yet,
so that the floor is the outside wall,
that's why in and that's how you get
your gravity.
That's how you get to grab it,
like in 2000,
2000,
one or one of them.
But space.
Honestly,
the thing spinning the space station was
spinning.
So by spinning it creates a false sense
of gravity.
Uh oh,
I know what it was in 2001 where he was
running along that curved interior.
So it's,
it's,
it's spinning like this,
so it presses against the floor.
It's like those old carnival,
um,
things where you go in and you're
standing on the floor,
drops out,
is it spin and you spent on the outside.
That's right.
That's the same principle there.
Uh,
yeah.
So it's just amazing that ideas can come
out of nowhere.
The origin of ideas.
That's,
that's a fascinating thing to me.
Like creativity where,
how does one person come up with a great
idea for a movie?
How does someone come up with an amazing
idea for an invention?
Like where are these ideas emanating
from?
Well,
first of all,
you have to have some knowledge of what
it is you're trying to create,
you know,
you and I have a knowledge of evolution.
Yes.
he read quite a bit.
Yeah,
he was totally into this for years as
was darwin.
So the dream state,
even mozart,
you know,
he was composing since the age of four
and his father was a composer.
So it's not like this comes out of the
vacuum.
There's not abused that pops into your
head.
Um,
you know,
you and I are going to come up with an
einstein type dream because we're not an
einstein and we're not physicists and
uh,
you know,
so you have to have the balance seems to
be being ensconced in a field to know
what the problems are to be solved and
what the details are and what's already
been done.
You know,
they tried this to drive this,
this didn't work and so on,
but not be so entrenched in it that you
can't see outside the box and no one
knows what that is.
We know.
No,
it's just,
it's so interesting.
Creativity in and of itself is so
interesting because boom,
an idea,
you know,
like where's the,
how does that take place?
Like what is,
what's the birth of the idea,
what are the mechanisms that are going
on inside the mind that allow the
imagination to give birth to this idea
that's so it's so poorly understood and
part of the problem of trying to
understand it is the,
what I call the biography by us.
We only know abouT the successful people
right now.
So steve jobs and bill gates.
Okay.
So the thing is you go to college and
drop out,
you move into your parents' house,
you start a company in your garage,
and boom,
right?
Okay.
how many people did this back in the
seventies?
And we don't even know who they are
because they failed all those venture
capital startup companies that went out
of business.
You know,
all these great ideas.
Okay?
So we,
you know,
we don't know what the formula is a
well,
not only that,
what made you who you are right now at
12,
oh,
seven was a March 7th or whatever the
hell it is.
What made you,
you,
you're 60 plus years of life
experiences,
you know,
being awake for,
18 hours plus a day doing this,
doing that.
Like what,
what chain of events,
what foods did you eat,
how much sleep did you get?
What led these ideas to cross each other
and bank and a little fire gets lit and
that,
and then you write it down on a napkin
and your life changes and yet nobody
knows too many variables.
So fascinaTing.
So fascinating.
Just the mind and the way the mind
works.
It's a,
it's so,
it's such a mystery and yet there's so
much information about it at the same
time.
Yup.
Well,
it is the hardest problem I think in all
of science consciousness.
The brain.
How does it work?
I mean not we know how it works,
how the neuro neurons communicate with
each other.
Neurochemically and how say that your
visual cortex is see stuff,
but,
but what is it that you and I are doing
now?
just just we're experiencing this
process.
How does that happen?
And that no one knows.
We don't have a cogent theory of
consciousness,
which is why then people step in with
quantum consciousness or you know,
whatever.
They have all these theories because we
don't know those people get.
They get me baffled.
I've had a few of those people and have
conversations with people about quantum
consciousness and you're like,
what?
No,
I don't even know what you're saying.
I don't even know if you know what
you're saying.
That's exactly right.
So you know,
quantum physics is a,
it is difficult in spooky and
consciousness is difficult and spooky,
but that doesn't mean they're related.
You know,
maybe they're related,
but maybe they're not relating.
Well,
I'm glad someone's out there exploring
and I check in on him every now and
then.
How you doing over there?
Absolutely.
that's the theory is evolving.
I'm not sure.
Yeah.
I'm not sure about any of it,
but listen man,
we're,
we're basically out of time.
We just did three hours yet.
Crazy.
That was crazy.
I really appreciate your time and you're
getting all your work over the years.
That's really been wonderful to read and
have you on here and thank you for
saying so.
Is this your most recent?
Yep.
You can take that with you on your
vacation to very,
very much the moral consciousness.
Yeah,
I'm going,
I'm going.
And uh,
if people want to get ahold of you on
twitter,
it's michael shermer on twitter website
skeptic.com
or michael shermer.
Dicom.
Thanks sir.
Appreciate it.
You're welcome.
Thanks for having me folks.
See ya.
Mm.
Alright,
cool.